- When I was 12, or
something, we were shown
"Big Bird Goes to Japan"
and then everybody came
to me, all of the sudden,
and they were like,
"Do you have a kimono?"
(all laughing)
"Do you pay in yern?"
- "Do you eat sushi everyday?"
(Reina laughing)
(chill music)
- Welcome back to the Trash Taste Podcast.
I'm your host and, unfortunately,
I'm hosting with a guest
sometime now, fuck.
- We've completely messed up
the order now, haven't we?
- I know.
It used to be that Garnt
was the always the host.
- I saw that!
That it was notoriously always you.
- Yeah, and none of them has aired yet,
but, like, Joey's hosted
the last two guests.
So, I'm sure, like, the subreddit
is in anarchy right now.
(Reina laughing)
- It's like the meta-verse
has been destroyed.
- And now it's my time to host.
With the wonderful
Reina Scully, of course.
- The honor!
Thank you so much for having me!
(guys agreeing)
- It has been a fuckin' millennia
since we all caught up with you.
- It's been quite a while.
Well over two years between us.
Well over three years between us.
And never.
- Yeah, I think I met you--
- Oh, is it the first time for you?
- Well, I met you very, very briefly.
But you don't probably remember.
- Uh oh! Oh no!
(guys groaning)
When, when?
- It was at AX,
but you were cosplaying
as, like, Chun Li I think.
- Oh yeah, that sounds about right.
- And you were like,
I was like, "Oh, hi."
'cause I was with Joey.
- That was the first
time I met you, right?
- No, that was two years after.
- No one knows where anyone met.
(all laughing)
- We met in 2016.
- Was it really?
- Yeah!
- Fuck.
- And then, it was crazy
'cause after we met,
then we, like, randomly shot in Japan,
and I was like, "I need to
go buy a bunch of eroge."
And we were like, "Yeah,
let's make a video out of it."
(all agreeing)
- We spent like six hours
in that one eroge shop.
- I think I remember watching this video.
- I remember that video as well.
- I made like an animated
vlog about it, right?
- Yeah, because it was too messed up!
- Yeah, because otherwise
it would've just been
censor bars for 15 minutes.
- I did that.
I just had, like, mosaics the whole time.
Like, for seven minutes straight,
it's just like us talking
and mosaics and then
cutting really dangerously.
- Well, it's like being on
a Zoom call in public now,
with the filter behind you.
It's like, "Hi, everyone,
here's the video."
And just everything is blurry around her.
- 'Cause I remember watching that video,
I remember thinking it looked like,
you know one of those
undercover cop videos?
(Joey laughing)
where they like bust, like,
the pedophile or something.
And you just like sneakily
going around the shop.
- (grumbles) So, what's
your favorite orgasm?
(all laughing)
- Oh no!
- Sorry, before we jump right
into the deep end of content,
I think, Reina, you should
probably introduce yourself
to the audience who might
not know who you are.
- Yes!
I don't really know what I do anymore.
(guys chuckling)
Because, due to the pandemic,
I had to, like, really kind of
do different things than I normally do.
But, I do, do YouTube.
I'm normally a host for other
channels like First We Feast.
I have a show called Gochi
Gang where we go around--
- Right, I totally forgot.
You've literally, like,
done everything, I swear.
(guys agreeing)
I always saw you as like a
YouTube jack of all trades.
Like, you were, like, always everywhere,
just hosting something.
- That's so nice of you, thank you.
- No, I'm being serious!
- What the fuck!
I'm gonna cry!
(guys laughing)
I'm sorry, I'm filled with emotions.
This is also the first time I've, like,
collaborated physically with
another person in a whole year.
So, even, like, physical contact
with another person is
kind of intense for me.
(all laughing)
- Oh, my god, it's real.
- Yeah, like, "Ooh!"
And we're speaking English.
But yeah, normally, I'm a host.
And then I also do some voice work.
I, obviously, do YouTube.
But, for now, it's
really just to, kind of,
keep myself as relevant as possible
until my hosting gigs come back.
(guys humming agreement)
But, yeah.
- 'Cause most of your
hosting gigs are overseas?
- Yeah, they're overseas.
And also, even like voicing stuff,
I recently just did a
couple Japanese voices
for some video game companies here,
but I had to record
myself, alone in my home.
And, like, I don't have any idea!
Like, I had to use my own
mixer and I was so scared, so.
Even, like, I don't even
go to studios anymore.
So, again, this is very exciting.
(guys laughing)
- I'm honored, thank you.
(all laughing)
- Well, I mean, like, I
guess how I found you,
and I think how a lot of
people also know you is,
back in the day, you were on SourceFed.
- Yes! Okay, yeah.
That is definitely where.
- Literally, Reina has done everything.
- I completely forgot!
- Reina has been around forever, dude.
- I completely forgot
that's how I discovered you.
(all laughing)
- You're like royalty.
- There's actually an ongoing
joke about how I'm 42.
(guys laughing)
I actually came on this
podcast, specifically,
to destroy that rumor.
- Dispel the rumors!
- Yes, that's what I came here to do.
- Destroy people with facts and logic.
- Yes! And I have to
throw you under the bus,
- Me?
- Yeah, yeah yeah!
Two years ago when we were
doing that Hanami thing,
in one of the videos, you
loudly and jokingly were like,
"No, she's really 42!
"Everybody believe me!"
And everyone believed you.
(guys laughing)
And you had like the silliest look
and you were just, like, running around,
just, like, yelling and
yet, they all believed you.
- They want the truth more, you know.
- It bothers me so much!
Like, as I get older and as
I, like, approach that age
and that, like, curve gets closer.
- Well, it'll be right eventually, right?
You know, a broken clock is
right two times a day, right?
That's the saying?
- People will watch that video next year
and be like, "Well,
she's actually 42 now."
- Ugh, next year!
I was like nodding at
first, I was like, "Yeah!"
(all laughing)
- But yeah, I feel you're one
of those YouTube personalities
where it's kind of like
everyone knows who you are,
but there isn't like a
specific moment in time
where people came to know you.
You're one of those
personalities where it's like,
I mean, if you watch YouTube all the time.
- She's hosting everything I like!
- It's the kind of name
and face where it's like,
"Yeah, I've definitely seen you somewhere
"but I can't pinpoint where."
- Right, I can't place it.
I get that a lot.
- You've been involved in
so many different projects,
and so many different channels,
as like the professional host
that if anyone's in,
like, the nerd industry,
especially the anime industry,
they've definitely seen your face around.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah, I worked really
hard in the beginning.
So, to establish myself at SourceFed,
they obviously wanted,
they were ramping up to gain other hosts,
and I was their third generation host.
And they definitely
wanted to get into anime.
And before that, I was translating anime
for fan subs and for Crunchyroll.
So, I made sure I secured
that professional angle,
so that I have like
something to fall back on
- You had some cred, yeah.
- Exactly, it's not just like,
"Oh, promise I know
what I'm talking about."
It's like, "No, I know
the technical stuff."
So, I can kind of delve into
really strange things if I need to,
or things that people don't
really reveal normally.
- So, SourceFed was like
the first big thing.
- Yeah, I would say so.
- How did you get involved with that?
- Yeah, and I'm also curious 'cause,
and I'm sure the viewers are
going to be the same way,
I know, I've heard SourceFed,
all I know is that Philip DeFranco was
jumping right into it back then with that.
- Aw!
- I don't really--
- Sup Nation.
(all laughing)
I get sued by Phil.
- I don't know, fully, what SourceFed is.
So, maybe explain to
the audience what it is,
and how it became a thing.
- Sure, sure.
So, SourceFed was pretty,
I'd say, like, OG YouTube,
where they started with this thing
called 20 Minutes Or Less,
and they'd have these
really quick, short segments
where they'd delve into news
but make it really comedic
because the original,
OG three were comedians
and they were very intellectual, too.
So, they knew how to mold the
story into a very digestible,
but also like a funny way.
So, they were really good
at selecting stories.
And they obviously, purposefully,
did not choose, like,
intense or, like, depressing things.
And they really made
a name for themselves.
- They left the depressing
shit to Philly D., right?
(all laughing)
- At least Phil would, like,
he has a little bit of
a long-form platform,
where he's able to talk about it.
So, it's not like
dismissing it, necessarily.
So, but yeah, I think they were part of
the original YouTube start-up program,
where I think Phil was
given start-up money
from YouTube to start up SourceFed.
- [Joey] Really?
- Yeah.
And that's how he, kind
of, rag-tag handled that.
Hired the three.
- This was when the partnership
program was just, like,
really early days, right?
- Yeah, and very exclusive.
- Where people were just like,
"Oh, you can make money
from being a YouTuber?
"What is going on?"
- This is like 2009, 2010 maybe.
- [Joey] Damn.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Because I was an intern in 2012.
Actually, that's how they found me.
I moved to LA for fun
and also I was, like,
sick of the snow in New
Jersey, that's where I grew up.
And I auditioned for,
well, I didn't audition,
I got hired as one of their interns.
And I was like Phil's intern, as well.
And he had me guest host (sighs)
he had me guest host
a sexy ladies segment.
(all laughing)
- Oh my god.
- I remember when Phil would do that.
- I mean, views from
the thumbnails, right?
(all agreeing)
- It's like, that was the first
time I was ever on camera.
- So, how did this pitch come about?
He's like, "Listen, Reina,
"I've got a job that only you can do."
- Did you apply for this?
- No, I was just his intern.
I was, like, getting
him lunches and coffee.
And I was just doing some, like,
research for metadata, kind of thing.
- Was it a thing where,
"I don't want this to
seem too misogynistic.
"Could you, like, spice
it up a little bit?"
- That was actually, exactly it.
- Okay, okay.
- Like, I can't even tell
you how exact that was.
- I know you, Phil.
- Yo, yo, yo, Ashley,
do you want to host a new segment for us?
(all laughing)
- And it literally, like,
the segment was called,
"Intern Reina Brings In The Sexy Ladies."
(guys laughing)
- You can't make this shit up.
- So, that happened.
- That's probably your past
that Phil kind of wants to,
like, brush under the rug, right?
- That is the most 2012
sounding title I've ever heard.
- It is!
- So, that's when Phil started
jumping right into it, huh?
- I had to say, "Sup, Nation?"
That's why it like rings in my head.
But it was actually a lot of fun.
And Darren was the cameraman at the time,
he was the producer.
And he was so good.
And he was, like, so professional.
And he really, I don't know,
he, like, brought me
into this new world of
being not an intern but talking on camera.
And I was so nervous, but it
was just, like, so much fun.
And also, it was talking
about sexy ladies!
Which I was like, "Yeah! I'll do that!"
- You could be talking about worse things.
- Yeah!
The worst part about it though,
was that it was this new fresh 18 girl,
who was being, I guess, like,
being Googled before that,
but she like just turned 18, so it's like,
"It's legal now!"
And I had to like do that.
Yeah, so.
- Oof.
- YouTube 10 years ago was
a different planet, man.
- It was.
- And that was like monetized.
- Can only imagine.
It makes me feel sad that
when you refer to SourceFed,
you're like, "Oh, it's
an OG YouTube channel."
And I'm just like, "Oh shit,
I guess it is, isn't it?
"Oh, fuck!"
- You're an OG YouTube channel.
- I keep forgetting!
'Cause like, I've been
following Phil since, like,
close to when he started, right?
So, I remember when he
announced SourceFed,
I was like, "Ooh, what's this
new venture that he's doing?
"This sounds exciting."
And now that it's like
now an OG dead channel
that is just buried in people's memories,
like, that makes me feel a bit sad!
I'm just having this
realization live on camera.
- I used to watch SourceFed a lot.
- Oh my god.
- Like, fuckin' like, yeah.
I used to watch it a lot.
That was like, at one point, I would say
it was probably one of my
favorite channels to watch.
- [Reina] Wow!
- Just because it's,
again, it's, you know,
it wasn't like as, you know,
I watch Philly D. as well, obviously,
for, like, the news stuff.
But it was also just like,
it was edutainment, right?
- Yes! Exactly.
- That was like the big
selling point for it.
It was like, you get to learn some shit
but at the same time, you can
have fun with these comedians.
(all agreeing)
- You kind of remember
it because it's funny.
I think that was also
the other point of it.
Like, it's shareable
because it's not dark,
and it's also funny,
so it makes sense to, like,
put all over Facebook, kind of thing.
Everybody else can watch it
and be entertained by it.
So, yeah, it was like a brilliant idea
and they started making
other sub channels,
like SourceFedNERD and then
I ran their gaming channel,
Super Panic Frenzy, with Steven Suptic.
And that was like my golden time, I'd say.
That was when I was already, finally,
comfortable being on
camera, it was really fun.
And then I left for Crunchyroll.
So, (laughs)
- So, what made you leave?
- I was really heartbroken
that they canceled
Super Panic Frenzy, my gaming channel,
because we were hitting all the numbers.
Like, hard.
We were completely setting all the goals.
And at the time,
we were owned by Discovery
Digital Networks.
- Yeah.
- I remember that whole thing.
- I remember SourceFed ending
and then they tried to continue it
under a different name
or something, right?
(guys agreeing)
- That's, yeah, that was bad.
I think it's, like, a completely
different company now.
But right when SourceFed, like,
when Discovery let go of SourceFed,
somebody tried to pick
it up and kind of, like,
almost zombie reanimate it, like,
still using the audience and usurping it.
- Yeah, like, they took the same channel,
re-named it and hired different hosts
to continue on the show.
- As though, yeah.
It felt very, like, puppeted and strange.
- It kind of felt like you
went to a friend's house
and there was just a
stranger sitting there
pretending to be your friend.
- This is my house now.
- Wait a minute, what's going on?
I'm at Connor's house.
- Welcome back, Garnt!
(all laughing)
Good to see you back here.
- It was like, "Hold
on, that's not Connor,
"that's Connor animatronic!"
(all laughing)
- That's so worrying, oh my god.
I didn't follow any of the
SourceFed stuff, at all.
I think, on YouTube,
I was not watching that
kind of stuff then.
I think 'cause I was still
watching game-play stuff.
I was exclusively in Call
of Duty walk throughs
or some stupid shit.
- That's not stupid shit,
I was into that too.
- Don't lie.
(Reina laughing)
- Can we talk about SourceFed Anime?
Or what was the anime
show you had on SourceFed?
- Oh, SourceFed Animated.
- Yeah.
- Yeah! That was fantastic!
We had Andre, this independent animator,
make animations of short
clips from things like
our podcasts and our table talks.
And they were very good
because he was very good.
The animator did everything,
he like really expanded
the comedy on our behalf.
- Oh, not SourceFed Animated.
- Anime Club?
- Oh, Anime Club!
Oh, okay, sorry! I should've
like figured that out.
- I know none of these.
- I should've figured that out, yeah.
- With, what was it? William Hanes, is it?
- William Hanes.
- I remember when that came out,
and I was like, "Shit, I'm
going to be out of business."
- Yeah, actually, so, Anime
Club existed before me
and Meg Turney was doing it.
(guys agreeing)
and she kind of did it like--
- All these names sound so
familiar, but not quite.
I don't like have a face to put to them.
- Well, Meg Turney now
is like a cosplayer.
- Yeah and she's a sexy model.
And yeah, she's doing great.
And we still keep in
touch, I miss her a lot.
She misses Japan.
But yeah, so she started it
and I do believe they wanted to expand it,
and it would obviously make
sense if somebody who, like,
has some kind of professional
experience with anime
was on it as well, on top
of like being Japanese,
that's kind of a no-brainer there.
So, I was legitimately
hired mainly to do that,
to fill that role.
And it was just when
she was on her way out.
So, I basically replaced her.
And yeah, and then Will
and I took it over.
But, it was fun, but it
was really difficult.
'Cause the style was supposed to be
that I was a so-called expert,
kind of teaching the novice.
And he has all these questions
but they're so, very
left-field that, like,
I didn't know how to kind
of bring it back. (laughs)
- Because I think that,
all respect to Meg Turney,
I remember when she was
handling Anime Club,
which was like season one of Anime Club,
it started a lot of,
let's say, controversial opinions
within the anime community.
- [Reina] Right, right, right.
- 'Cause I remember it was the
first time where we saw this
kind of mainstream YouTuber try to, like,
bring the anime culture to the
wider, mainstream audience.
Nowadays, it's like pretty--
- Every brand is like,
"Hey, I like anime!"
(all agreeing)
- Everyone talks about anime now.
- "We at Arby's love anime."
- Back then, we had this like anime show,
that was like produced by Philly D.
or he had his name
involved with SourceFed,
and this was like the most
mainstream anime had gotten
to any YouTuber.
And, you know, all my love to Meg.
There was like some episodes
where some lines were said,
where I can't remember if it
was her or like her guest host,
where they called Full Metal
Alchemist a shoujo anime.
(guys laughing)
- I could feel unbridled grudge
in you as you're talking.
- You remember how anime fans
were back in the day, right?
They saw this medium as,
like, a fucking holy grail.
- I think it didn't help, as
well, that the show itself,
was probably the most well
produced out of, like,
any ani-tube content.
- [Reina] Of course, yeah.
- At the time.
So, it just felt like, you know, like,
"Yes, I too watch anime,
younger generation!"
- 'Cause I felt like it wasn't her fault.
It was just the fault of just,
I think the way the show was set up
just wasn't the right way to, like,
really embrace the medium of anime
or like introduce it to a new audience.
But, I'll say this,
like, what you and William did
- Aw!
- You made like,
it was a huge improvement, right?
Because I feel like the
chemistry was a lot better.
But what I wanted to ask is that,
did you, going into this,
did you know about all
of the negative feedback
that you had gotten
from, like, anime fans?
- Um, as a translator, I
was already pretty connected
to a lot of different anime sites.
So, I was well aware.
Well, "well aware" isn't
the right way to say it.
I was aware.
But, putting a face to the
opinion is a whole nother world.
(guys agreeing)
and the backlash is quite scary.
However, exactly how you said,
I think people were quite
excited about the improvement.
And there's a lot less you
can criticize to a translator.
(guys humming in agreement)
And also, I'm like actually Japanese.
So, that like kind of mattered
in their eyes, as well.
That's also like another creepy thing
about anime fans, right?
Like, especially back in the day.
There's like so much more nerd cred
if you're like actually Japanese.
That means you can watch it without subs!
- Joey's like, "Is there?"
- I would argue that
still exists to this day.
- No, it does, it totally does.
- Right, no, it does, it does.
Yeah, I was trying to
be like modest about it.
But that mattered
and I think that overrode
any major, major criticisms.
And also, again, I was
already in that sphere,
so I was conscious of what
to say, what not to say.
If Will said something weird,
I'd go to the producer and the editor
and be like, "You've got to
cut that out." (guys laughing)
- 'Cause like, I've always been curious,
because, you know, no disrespect to Meg,
it felt like you did take
a lot of the criticisms
that they had gotten
and really used that to improve the show.
And I was wondering if it was,
like, a conscious decision?
- Very conscious, yes.
Very conscious.
It really was unfair to Meg,
because she was the only
person in the entire building
that even knew anything about anime.
(guys agreeing)
The editors didn't know.
So, she had to source
all the photos herself.
I mean, granted, I did
too, after I took over.
But, there was no producer that oversaw
what was correct or incorrect,
or knew the sub-audience or like,
knew how to, like, hunt Reddit
for it and stuff like that.
So, I came in and I kind of
started from the back-log.
And I was, due to the
research, I knew everything
that would make sense, would maybe hit,
would be bad, is Will going to understand?
Like, that was also the
other tether, right?
Like, you have to make sure
that the novice character
is going to be able to
kind of follow it, as well,
without having to use like, high level--
- 'Cause, I guess, he needs
to like channel people
who are watching the video that
don't know anything about it.
- Right, right, right.
But, again, sometimes he was so random,
that it was hard to be like,
"Nobody's thinking that!"
(all laughing)
"Nobody thinks that, don't ask that!"
- It sounds like before,
it was a situation where,
like, the teacher's like,
"Oh, that one kid's good at computers,
"he can fix everything, right?
"Get him in."
- That's exactly what it felt like.
It felt like Meg just
got put in there because
she was the only one that knew
anything about anime at all.
- And you know it's awful because
it was such a passion project of hers.
And she wanted to do it as a fan,
but you have to get technical.
You have to.
(guys agreeing)
Especially if you don't have
a producer and an editor
that's gonna fix it on your
behalf after you're done.
Like, she wanted it to
be opinionated, and fun,
and what she likes, and that
would've worked maybe now.
But that was so not the case
on a platform like SourceFed.
So, it just did not work at the time.
- I feel like, you were like,
that idea was a few
years ahead of it's time.
In terms of a talk show about anime
that could really do well on YouTube now.
I feel like, back then, there was no way,
it was really hard to get
new people into anime.
Especially on YouTube.
- [Reina] I think so.
- And a lot of the backlash you got
were just from anime fans, as being like,
"Okay, no, we don't want this to be
"the representation of
what anime fans are."
And now I just think,
"Anime fans were pretty
fucking toxic back then,
"as well, weren't they?"
- Yeah.
- I mean, they still are.
Love you, guys, but we are.
Love you, guys.
- But I feel like early YouTube,
they were like next level.
- Well, yeah, 'cause
I think at that point,
again, it was like god saying,
or it was like the holy grail,
it was like this protected thing,
where it was like it was theirs
and it had been like tarnished.
- I kind of understand that, though.
Like, when I was younger
and I was in Japanese
school in New Jersey,
when Pokemon came to the States,
I was like, "That's ours!"
(guys laughing)
Like, "What are you doing?!"
- How dare you?!
- His name is Ash?!
Like, you know what I mean?
(guys agreeing)
Like, even as a kid I kind of understood
that exclusivity thing.
Also, like, as an anime fan,
I understood anime fans.
And I actually, surprisingly,
didn't get as much hate
especially throughout SourceFed.
They were actually very
happy that I existed.
So, I was super lucky there.
Got a lot of hate on Crunchyroll. (laughs)
- I think it was just
because it was so obvious
that you were just a
weeb through and through.
- Yeah.
- People just saw you
and they were just like,
"Okay, she's one of us now."
- I got accepted, yes.
- You weren't trying to
pretend to be a weeb,
you were a weeb.
- A lot of the time with these,
you know, company videos,
so much of it is like,
"Hi, guys. We love the
thing that you love, right?
"It's kind of wacky, huh?
"This thing's wacky, too?
"Oh, you guys, this is so wacky."
- "FMA, my favorite shoujo!"
- "FML, this was a cringe
moment, right guys? Ugh!"
- I wanted to give people
the benefit of the doubt
back then, and there was like that thing
that was in one show,
and I think the other thing,
one of them was talking about Baccano,
and I think the guy that
was new there, he said,
"Oh, it kind of feels like
a rip off to FMA, right?"
(Connor laughing loudly)
"'Cause Baccano's set on a train
"and there's an episode of
FMA that's set on a train."
(guys laughing)
and even that, that was like
the space bar moment for me, as well.
- Oh my god.
- And I just think you did such a good job
because this is the
environment that you came into
to have to prove people that,
okay there is an actual big
improvement to this show
and you did a great job.
- Does that video still exist on YouTube?
- Sorry?
- I think season one of Anime Club
- We've got to find this.
- is not on YouTube anymore.
- That's like being like,
"So, like, Train to Busan
is a little bit of a rip off
"of Hogwarts because they're
both on a train, right?"
- So, unfortunately, you're just going to
have to take my word,
but anyone who watched SourceFed
back in the day, in the anime community,
knows that, that was like shared around.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Right, so I'm trying to pull
up the timeline in my head.
So, you're in SourceFed for how long?
- I was there for, damn.
Let's see, I was an intern
first, which was 2012.
I was a actual host in 2014.
I was there for two years, no,
I was there for three years.
But it felt like much longer.
- Well, it sounds like
a really important part
of, like, the career.
- Absolutely! Yeah!
And I also did a lot of
things with them afterwards.
So, it kind of really did
feel much longer than that.
(guys agreeing)
- And so, the reason why
you left is obviously,
'cause did it just get wiped?
- Well, I left before that.
- Oh, okay, okay.
- Yeah, so this is such a strange thing.
I never talked about it before,
but my everything went
into our gaming channel.
Me and Steven Suptic's.
And we were doing so well!
And then they canceled it anyway.
And I was so heartbroken.
- Did they say why?
- They just said that
there was no budget for it.
Which is such a, I know.
- To let play?
Like, what?
Like, they buy the game on Steam.
- Yeah, I know!
It's crazy.
- We don't have $10 for the Steam game.
- But I must say, Suptic
did spend over two grand
on CS Go cases once.
(guys laughing)
Using the company card and we wrote it off
and it was like okayed.
That's their fault!
They should've just
told us it wasn't okay!
- That is hilarious.
That is such an epic gamer move.
- Yeah, I know.
And he got, like, the
fuckin' butterfly knife.
(guys laughing and cheering)
So, like, whatever!
But anyway (laughs)
Well yeah, they said there was no budget.
And there's like a lot of, like,
production reasons behind it.
But then because the whole
channel was dissolved,
and I was a OG host
for that time,
they brought me back into SourceFedNERD,
and SourceFed Proper instead of, like,
outright laying me off.
But they laid off Suptic
and I was like so weird about that,
but I also needed money to survive in LA.
So, there was not much
I could do about it.
And then, when I left,
Suptic got hired again
as, like, a SourceFed Proper member.
- [Garnt] What?
- I know, I know, so strange.
Yeah, and that's when I kind of realized
that something was super, super wrong
with the entirety of the company.
Not that there's anything
wrong with Steve!
But you know the fact that like--
- Letting someone go and then
bringing them back in
later is really bizarre.
- Yeah, and then it almost felt like
they were trying separate us
so that we wouldn't try
something on our own,
but then we did.
(guys agreeing) But then we
did, so that didn't work.
But yeah, that was like a major thing.
Also, you know, Discovery,
like, owned our face and soul
for X amount of years,
according to our contract.
'Cause we were an ensemble cast.
- [Garnt] Oh god, oh god.
- So that was also, I'm
suspecting that was also
why they maybe wanted to keep us separate,
so that our faces wouldn't
be together on another thing
that we created on our own.
- Because you and Steve
created like a brand,
almost created like a brand for your own.
- Yeah, we ended up,
like, kind of doing that.
Which was amazing, but
also, I do think that,
that probably was
dangerous for the company
and for the shareholders maybe.
- 'Cause the thing about, you know,
big companies hiring YouTubers
to do videos for the company,
is that the audience end
up being loyal to the host
and the personality,
because they're the heart
and soul of the show.
So, even if they leave,
you've already created a
brand for yourself, right?
And yeah, I mean,
it fucking is pretty scummy
that stuff like that happens.
- It sucks that, like, now
having been in the industry
in many different ways, like
as an independent YouTuber,
as somebody that's hired
by bigger companies,
like, it's entertainment,
media, new media, old media,
it kind of be helped right now.
I think it's starting to improve
or maybe change in a way
that's beneficial to independent creators.
Especially with YouTube and
Twitch and everything like that.
But, it's still very difficult.
Like, the biggest chunk
of money that's solid
is definitely still in the
hands of bigger companies.
So, that does definitely kind of sway.
- Yeah, and what I wanted to know is,
you've obviously got involved in this
by being an intern for Philly D.
Is that the job that you wanted?
Like, did you want to work in YouTube?
- Um, I was a fan.
And I was just watching him
and I was watching some of SourceFed
and I was, what was I doing?
Oh yeah, I was an apprentice
pastry chef in New Jersey.
(guys laughing in disbelief)
Yeah, I know, I know.
After having graduated from college.
- Is that what you wanted to do though?
- Um...
This is so weird, I knew I was good at it.
Sounds so pretentious.
I don't mean it to be, but
I knew I was good at it.
(all laughing)
- Well I mean, you became
an apprentice, right?
So, I guess it makes sense.
- Just own it, Reina.
"I was fucking amazing."
- I was like really good at it.
(all laughing)
I was making wedding cakes
and I actually made Japan Airlines'
first class desserts for a year.
- [Joey] Damn.
- Yeah, that was me!
- Fuckin' hell.
- So, she was pretty fucking good at it.
- What the fuck.
- So, I was doing that,
but I didn't like it
'cause you have to go
to work at 1, no, 2AM.
Then, you're out at like 12, 1PM.
But it's like, I don't know,
I got kind of depressed, I think.
Not like, actually depressed,
but I was not well.
- That doesn't really leave
you much time to do anything.
Because obviously you
need to sleep, right?
- Right! So, you try to
sleep during the day,
but I don't know, I was younger--
- That's when everyone wants to do stuff.
- Yeah! I was younger and I was like,
"I want to like party and
play and do all these things!"
So, I don't think it made a lot
of sense for me at the time.
And then, my now husband,
but then roommate slash
boyfriend and I were like,
"Let's just do something crazy."
And we moved to LA and I just,
we actually auditioned together.
I got it, he didn't.
(all laughing)
- This episode is sponsored by Ritual.
- [Connor] We deserve to know
what we're putting in our bodies and why.
Especially when it comes to
something we take everyday.
Ritual's clean,
vegan-friendly multi-vitamin
is formulated with high quality nutrients
in bio-available forms
your body can actually use.
- Gentlemen, let me tell you
what you won't find in Ritual.
Sugars.
- No!
- [Garnt] GMOs.
(guys gasping)
Major allergens, synthetic fillers,
and artificial colorants.
- No way.
- What?!
- [Garnt] Can you believe it?
- No!
- [Garnt] Plus, the fresh taste
and delay release capsule design
makes taking your vitamins easy.
- Holy fuck.
Why am I not taking these already?
- [Joey] Ritual is made traceable.
You'll always know what
nutrients you're taking
and where they come
from thanks to Ritual's
one-of-a-kind visible supply chain.
- I love when I know the things
that I put into my mouth.
- [Connor] So, get those
key nutrients today,
without the BS.
Ritual is offering our listeners
10% off during your first three months.
Visit ritual.com/trashtaste
to start your Ritual today.
(guys laughing)
- I see what you did there!
- Back to the episode.
- So, you auditioned with your husband?
- Yeah, and I got it and
it kind of mesmerized me.
As a fan, being able to be
on the opposite side of it,
and being the intern that
like researches stuff.
And I do believe there was
a lot of political stuff
going on at the time.
So, I was also re-educated,
which was really interesting for me,
having been out of college already.
I was like, "Oh, this is so much fun,
"There's so much to learn."
And then Phil wanted me to be on camera
and I was like, "No way.
"You want me to bring in
these sexy girls? Okay!"
(all laughing)
- I thought you'd never ask!
- Yeah, I was like, "I
was here to do that!"
That was my plan!
- Oh my god.
- Wow.
- Yeah so, it really started as a fan,
for lack of a better term.
I wasn't like an obsessive
fan, but there wasn't--
- I mean, I don't think
he would've hired you
if you were an obsessive fan.
- I know, he would've,
like, smelled it right away.
(all laughing)
- So, what came after SourceFed, then?
- After SourceFed, I went
straight to Crunchyroll.
- You were just given an offer or?
- Yeah, I was given an offer.
And I was actually given an offer
while I was at SourceFed and I was like,
"Oh no! I didn't hear that!"
(guys laughing)
"Nothing happened!"
but then after I left,
we had, like, a clean
break with SourceFed.
They knew I was so distraught
over the gaming channel.
So, they were like, "No, no, no, please,
"we don't want you to like, go postal.
"So just, like, leave."
So, I went to Crunchyroll and
it was actually a lot of fun.
But, I ended up shouldering
a lot of the production.
I thought it was going
to be more like SourceFed
where there's a crew and I
would have some production say
but they hired me as
talent slash producer,
so I guess I should've been expecting
more of that responsibility.
But, it was really rag tag.
And, like, you know, what you
were saying before, Garnt,
about the anime community,
Crunchyroll has a very
aggressive anime community.
- Oh, we know, don't worry. (laughs)
- Yeah, and it's like both a
good thing and a bad thing.
'Cause some people are fans of the company
that just want the company to do well.
But then there are people
that are like criticizing it.
Which makes sense, too.
The company should do better, right?
Like, there's a lot of,
kind of, factors to it
where you can't really get
mad at the whole situation.
And it was hard answering
all of that, right?
Like, it was hard to, like--
- I feel like you got an
impossible job, you know.
- Thank you so much,
that mean so much to me.
Can you say it one more time
so I can like lock it in?
Just one more time!
- You had an impossible job.
- Ah, thank you, I needed that.
Thank you so much.
- The words that she
wants to hear, gamers.
- Whisper the five words.
(all laughing)
- You don't even understand!
- Five words that make you do this.
- I mean, you were just like
a martyr for Crunchyroll.
- [Garnt] Honestly!
- Like, you know, every time
I saw Crunchyroll videos,
you know, I think 'cause
everyone just has that
air of skepticism towards Crunchyroll,
unfortunately, you know?
- Of course, yeah.
- You know, we've worked with Crunchyroll,
and I think we've also been
skeptical of Crunchyroll.
But, I think the viewers especially
love dogging on Crunchyroll.
- I mean, Crunchyroll could've hired--
- They're the boogeyman.
- Yeah, Crunchyroll could've hired
like, fucking Jesus Christ, you know.
- Keanu Reeves, literally.
- Well, Keanu Reeves, same thing, right?
And people would've
found problems with them.
- I feel Crunchyroll fans,
well, not Crunchyroll fans
but Crunchyroll haters, quote unquote,
kind of get a little too over obsessive
with criticizing Crunchyroll,
to a point where it's
like, "Okay, I get it."
Yes, it's not a perfect company
and they have a lot of stuff to work on,
but give them a fucking break!
- [Reina] Aw, that means a lot!
- Like, Jesus Christ,
like, and especially again,
it's like, you had that
impossible job of like,
because I feel all of the arrows
were pointed towards you, right?
Because you were literally the face.
- Now they have a face.
- Yeah, now they have a face
and person to point at, right?
And I just felt really fucking bad
that you were at that point.
- I know, I remember you lined me.
You sent me messages being
like, "Are you okay?"
- I would send you messages
being like, "Are you okay?"
'cause like, if I were you,
I would not be able to
fucking handle that.
- Yeah, I remember actually,
I very, very specifically
and vividly remember
one of your messages where you
were like, "Hey, are you..."
and it was like so, you were
being so careful with me.
You were like, Are you okay?"
Like, "I saw the last video."
Like, "It's not your fault."
I was like, "Oh, um, you know what?
"I'm not reading the
comments anymore." (laughs)
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
I'm like, "I think I'm okay."
- It was just like a
warning call to be like,
don't read the comments.
- Yeah, I know.
- [Joey] Fucking hell.
- And it was so weird 'cause
I don't want to mention
specifically the video, but
they weren't even mad at me.
It wasn't me that they were mad at.
They were just mad at something
else that was happening,
which was ad related, and
they pushed it onto the video.
And then it kind of turned
into its own monster.
- It was a sticky situation.
- Yeah, and I'm like,
that's the weird thing,
they're not even mad at me!
Like, I can't really,
I didn't know how to feel about it, right?
Like, if they're not hating on me,
but I'm also the face, so they're like,
"Fuck you and your face and these ads!"
I'm like, "That's not my bad!"
- That's the weirdest kind of hate to get
as a content creator, I feel.
Where it's like, it's not
your fault but fuck you.
- Yeah, they're like, "I'm
so sick of seeing your face
"every five seconds, like,
"while I'm watching Attack On Titan."
And I was like, "I'm not even sorry."
(all laughing)
So, yeah that was interesting.
But again, because they weren't really,
necessarily angry at me as a person,
again, I had that,
like, veil of protection
(guys humming in agreement)
where I'm like, "Hm, it's okay.
"They hate my company that I work for
"and represent with my face."
But, yeah.
- Yeah, I mean, another question
I wanted to ask you, as well,
is, like, you've obviously
done a lot of hosting
and everything like that,
it seems like you kind of just
got thrown into it, you know?
Starting with Phil and SourceFed.
Did you ever go through any training
or was it just something
you learnt on the job,
how to present?
- I must say, the internship
taught me everything.
- [Garnt] Right.
- As an intern, you did so
much, just like (laughs)
- Just like Ashley is
back there, good on him.
- I see him taking notes!
Like, you know, there's
so much to be done.
- You're doing good, Ashley!
You're doing good.
- Fantastic, fantastic. No, seriously.
- He's just doing his uni work.
(all laughing) It's got
nothing to do with--
- Nevermind! But, you know,
you had to do so much,
especially back in the day.
Like, I learned cameras, I learned audio,
(guys humming in agreement)
I learned editing, I learned research,
metadata, everything.
I learned how to backwards engineer, like,
some of the algorithm,
because it was much
simpler back in the day.
(guys agreeing)
And then, I actually
worked for an advertising
slash gaming company for a little bit,
where they put me on camera,
because they just needed somebody
and I just happened to be a fast reader,
and I was good at reading the prompter.
(guys humming in agreement)
So, that's where I, kind of,
got my practice, so to speak.
But the bread and butter
of my technical knowledge
definitely came from the internship.
And then, I got to practice
being, like, a face
and, like, talking on camera,
and doing pauses or reading really fast,
or making sure the video cuts
at two minutes kind of thing.
And then, SourceFed came about
and I just, like, knew what I was doing.
(guys humming in agreement)
So, yeah.
- God, I wish I was as,
like, natural as you.
- No!
- Yeah, honestly.
- Being a YouTuber for 13 years now,
I still get a camera
pointed in front of me
and if I don't have you guys next to me,
I'm just like, "Uh, uh, h-h-hi guys!
"S-s-smash the like button!"
- Oh my, no, no, no, no.
- I'm just so, miserably, fucking British.
So, like, anytime I have
to fake being happy,
everyone know I'm not like that.
(guys laughing)
Like, when I'm like, "Yo, guys!"
Everyone's like, "Connor,
why are you faking it?"
- Yo, guys!
- Your mouth is smiling,
- [Connor] (cheerily) "Hi, guys!!"
- But your eyes say, "Death."
- "Let me tell you about this great show!"
And everyone is just like,
"Why is Connor talking like that?"
(guys laughing)
- The trick is drinking, like,
three Red Bulls beforehand.
- That doesn't sound sustainable.
(guys laughing)
- No, it's not!
And, like, you sweat
through all your clothes.
But, it works!
You can mimic that excitement.
- The Reina Scully Method.
- Yeah, three Red Bulls.
- Just destroy your heart.
- Yeah!
But you'll look good on camera!
(guys laughing)
Just, like, hide those
armpits and you're good.
- That's the same thing
as just saying, like,
"You know what I do? Do a line of coke."
- Yeah, I mean--
- "Right before I start."
- There's some people
though, that when they smile,
you're like, "Nice."
And then there's people like me,
where it's like, "Whoa, what the fuck?"
(all laughing)
- I don't know!
- I feel like when you smile,
on camera, it looks like
a real person smiling.
- Really?
- What do you mean?
You know what I mean.
(guys agreeing)
You just see--
- Aw!
- You're like, "That
looks like a real smile."
And other people, you know
when Garnt smiles too much?
I'm like, "What the fuck?"
(all laughing)
but I feel like the same for me.
When people see me smile,
they're like, "What's going--"
- There is a trick about,
like, smiling with your eyes,
where you, like, kind of want
to squint like this. (laughs)
- It's the these eyes, in anime, yeah.
- Yes, yes, yes!
That's what, like, you do
that and then you put up--
(Joey laughing loudly)
- [Joey] Connor's like (cackling)
- You look like someone's
holding you at gunpoint.
- I am.
- Being like, "Smile, motherfuckers!"
- (cheerily) Hi, guys!
Welcome to Trash Taste.
Connor here.
- But everyone knows you're genuine.
- If you just cut out, like, this half,
it just looks like you're doing--
- [Reina] Murderer.
- This is what I get, I
hate it when I live stream.
I wish I was a ViewTuber because
then people don't ask you,
"You look tired, Connor."
I always look fucking tired!
- That's so rude!
- "You look angry, Connor."
Like, yeah, I'm British.
I'm always angry, my face is
just naturally angry, right?
- To be fair, though, so
many of, like, your fans,
and even you, yourself, were like,
"I have a really serious
resting bitch face."
- I do, I do!
- I never noticed it, up
until you pointed that out.
- I do, though.
Now, like--
- Yeah, now I look at it, I'm like, yeah.
- Reina, what do you think?
- I mean, I don't really think so,
but that's because I
watch your streams a lot.
- Aw, get out of here.
- I lurk a lot.
Yeah, I'm really creepy.
- What simp.
- You never told me!
Reina walked in the studio and was like,
"I watch your live streams."
And I'm like, "How many?"
(all laughing)
- Like, a lot.
- What?!
That's so embarrassing.
- Come Chill pops up my--
- Just say something!
(Reina laughing)
- Yeah, why don't you tell me?
"Hey, Reina here!"
- Well, first of all, your
chat's bananas, right?
So, like, I'm not gonna jump into that.
But, I don't know, I mean I--
- I appreciate that.
- You know what, I was
discouraged by Joey (laughs)
- What the?
- Because--
- Why am I always, like (laughs)
- No, I watch all your
streams, by the way.
'Cause I'm creepy like that.
But, no, I watch yours quite often.
But when you jumped on for, like,
the first time in, like, maybe
two months, or something,
and I was like (speaking Japanese)
and you answered it without realizing--
- In Japanese.
- In Japanese!
- I didn't realize it
was her! (all laughing)
- And then I said
something else, like, not
(speaking Japanese)
not like, "I want to play
Smash Brothers" or something.
I said something gaming related,
and then you answered that too!
And you didn't realize it was me!
(all laughing)
- No, because, it's because,
like, especially recently,
I've had people because every time,
'cause I kind of advertise
my streams as like,
"I can also speak Japanese."
Right? So it's like--
- I thought I was helping you!
- Yeah, no, every now and
then I get like, post stream,
maybe, like, five to ten,
like, full on Japanese people
typing in my chat, and I
always reply back in Japanese.
I thought you were just
one of those people.
- I'm not even gonna lie--
- Wait, is your screen
name "Not Reina Scully?"
- It's Reina Scully!
(Garnt laughing loudly)
- I didn't read it!
(all laughing)
- And what's funny is,
like, I know that about you.
About, like, you say, "Live from Tokyo!"
And it's in Japanese and English, right?
So, I was like, "Oh, I be
he wants to talk Japanese."
- Yeah, of course I do!
- So, I purposefully wrote in Japanese,
you answered me for like five minutes,
and you didn't realize it was me.
And then you answered me again!
- I think I was, like, I
forgot what I was playing,
but I was probably, like,
really, intensely into the game.
- You weren't playing a game.
(all laughing)
- All right nevermind then.
- "I must've been tired."
"you weren't tired."
(all laughing)
- "You just woke up."
- "I must not have saw you."
"You literally said, 'Reina Scully'."
(all laughing)
- And didn't realize it was me.
- Wow.
- No excuses.
- But next time, I'll say something.
- All right, thank you, thank you.
Wait, you saw my cringey Japanese?
- Oh no, I didn't see that.
- Oh, thank god, thank god.
- But I watched, you were really
complaining about something
in one of the streams and it was so funny.
- What was I--
I complain about a lot of
things, that's just me, I think.
- I don't know, I forgot
what it was specifically,
but I don't know, it was really funny.
How do you make the
camera zoom in like that?
- Oh, I can teach you that, it's easy.
- It's called a stream deck.
- I'm so, I've only ever
streamed on behalf of a company.
So, I had, like, people taking care of it.
- Well, you were telling me the other day,
that you want to get into Twitch, right?
- I really do.
I really do!
- It's super easy!
- I mean, you could do it easily.
You seem like you're a personality
that was like made for
Twitch, I'll be honest.
- Oh my god, I really want to.
But again, I've only ever streamed
for other companies or other people.
So, I've never had to, like,
do all the technical stuff myself.
And I'm really afraid,
because once, at SourceFed,
we left the stream on and
we didn't do anything,
but it was just on for
like hours and hours.
Like, overnight.
Like, lights went dark and
the camera was still on.
- [Joey] Oh my god.
- They probably thought some,
like, meta ARG or something.
Like, "Oh my god, they're
telling us something!"
(guys laughing)
- You know, that would've been so cool.
But no, we're not that
clever, we're just dumb enough
to leave the camera on.
And, like, the whole thing was on,
like streamed fully, and stuff.
And then, when one of
our editors went home,
he was like (gasps).
Like, "What the fuck?"
And then he, like, went
back turned it all off.
(guys humming in agreement)
It's trauma!
- It's pretty hard to do
that, though, honestly.
- I know!
Yeah, especially from your home, right?
- Yeah, 'cause I mean, like--
- Trauma!
- Because, like, it's your PC.
You know it.
When I'm done streaming,
I'm probably still going to be at the PC.
(guys agreeing) So, I'm probably
going to, like, look at--
- Yeah.
- So, it's pretty easy.
- No, I know, it's like
an irrational fear.
- We'll help you, it'll be fine.
- Yeah, we'll help you.
- Stop! Oh my god, my heart.
I also realize that, like, on Twitch,
it's so much more fun to watch people
that are streaming with other people.
Co-streaming and playing a game together.
- Not always.
- Like Among Us, and stuff.
And I'm like, "I want friends."
- No, not always, that's not true.
- I feel it works both ways.
- I want friends!
Friends are good.
- I feel like, for half the people,
for me, it kind of goes both ways.
'Cause it's, like, sometimes
there are some people
who watch Twitch streamers because
they want to interact
with the actual person.
- [Reina] Totally.
- But if your favorite streamer is playing
with another streamer, or like
playing with another person,
most of the time, they're
not paying attention
to the chat as often as
if they're on their own.
(group agreeing) So, they're
like, "Well, what the fuck?
"Like, I came all this way,
I'm hanging out in the chat.
"I want your attention."
- "Acknowledge me."
- Yeah, "I want your acknowledgment."
- Yeah, I think, like,
once you stream enough,
your chat will understand if
you're playing with someone,
that you'll probably not be
paying attention to the chat.
- Right, and you'll, like,
cultivate that audience.
- It's like fifty fifty for me.
If I'm playing alone, I read the chat.
If I'm not, if I'm
playing with someone else,
I kind of ignore the chat.
- Yeah, I watched your stream with,
I think it was Iron Mouse?
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- Oh yeah, I love that one!
That was so much fun.
- Iron Mouse is crazy, she's great though.
- Well, is there anything you'd, like,
want to do if you start doing Twitch?
Like, do you want to play games?
Do you want to just do,
like, a just chatting?
- You know, I miss playing games.
I miss playing games, like,
for the purpose of being on camera.
So, probably fifty fifty.
- Reina Scully streams, coming soon.
- Oh my god, thank you!
Yeah, I think I just
want a different platform
than YouTube, right now.
That's really what it is.
I'm a little bit sick of
making YouTube videos.
We all feel it, don't be
like, "Oh, no!" (laughs)
- (sarcastically) No, I love it!
- It depends on how my
morning goes, you know.
- I feel that.
- Some days I'm like, "Fuck,
I don't want to do this."
- It also depends on the YouTube idea.
Some of them are literally just like,
"Okay, here's the grind. I'm
going to just grind it out."
Some projects you're excited for.
But it very much depends.
- Totally! Yeah, I think
it really is just, like,
a pandemic world thing.
I used to make a lot of videos
going out and going to Tokyo,
hanging out with Joey, like
doing a bunch of things.
And like with my friends in Tokyo.
And I don't like streaming from,
oh, not streaming,
I don't like shooting
from my house, because A
I don't want to accidentally
reveal where I am exactly.
Like, I'm in the inaka,
I'm in the countryside.
So, it's a little bit hard
to figure out where I am.
But, like, just in case,
it's a little bit freaky.
And, you know, I guess your inspiration
is kinda limited when you're just
doing it from home, by yourself.
- I mean, yeah, someone got very close to
finding where I live right now.
- Oh, what?
- Did I tell you this?
- No.
- So, there was, like, a bar code
that was roughly shown for, like, a second
in one of my videos, from
one of the packages I opened.
- Right.
- And they went around, texting people,
being like, "I know where Connor lives."
(Reina gasping)
And then, so, what happened was, was that
even though this bar
code was barely visible,
somehow, like, it's in the background,
and somehow it scanned.
- [Joey] What?!
- What?!
- When you put the scanner to it.
- That's what you meant?
I didn't understand at first.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, like, when you get a Japanese package,
I think any package,
there's always a bar code on it.
(group agreeing)
And this was, like, in the
background of the shot.
And someone, somehow scanned it.
I have no idea how they got,
like, the fidelity high enough.
- Enhance, enhance!
(all laughing)
- That's what I was thinking!
They did the enhancements.
- I found where it was,
it didn't even work when I was doing it.
So, I don't understand how
they managed to pull it off.
'Cause then they were going around,
sending me a screenshot like,
"I know where you live, Connor."
And then, so, I looked at the thing
and, luckily, Japan Post
only told my post code.
Which is still not good,
but I was like, "All right."
- It's only a post code.
- That's close, though.
- Yeah, I was like, "All
right, what are you gonna do?
"come to this giant-ass place,
"with all these, like,
ten story apartments?"
- And knock on every door.
- Yeah, I'm like,
"What are you gonna
do, find my apartment?"
I'm like, I would gamble
even if you found a building I lived in.
I'd still feel safe, honestly.
I'm like, "Try and find the door."
Don't try and find the
door, that was a joke.
- Oh my god.
- But, like, I mean, you know.
It was very concerning.
You should be careful with bar codes.
- Yeah, yeah, I had no
idea that was a thing.
- Fuck that person
going around being like,
"This is so cool, I have
Connor's address, I think."
- Don't be like that.
Don't do that.
- But it's whatever.
I mean, I was like, "All
right, cool, you're a loser."
Why would you see a bar code in the video
and think, "I'm gonna scan that.
"I'm gonna fuckin' try and scan that."
- They love you. (laughs)
- I love him so much I must
find out where he lives.
- I must dox him, that's
how much I love him.
- Yeah!
- I probably have
cockroaches in my apartment,
why would you want to
find out where I live?
I don't know.
- 'Cause he loves you
and your cockroaches.
(Connor chuckling)
- Everything about you, all of you.
- Oh god.
(Reina laughing)
- That's so fucking creepy.
- Yeah, it was.
- Yeah, that sucks.
- Yeah, but I mean, where you live though,
it's probably really safe though.
- It is!
Except we just had a stabbing.
- What?!
- First one in a hundred years or?
- That's what I'm saying!
It never happens, so it
freaked everybody out.
But yeah!
- Was this, like, national news?
- Um, it was definitely, like--
- Did they die?
- Yeah.
- Oh shit, I thought, fuck.
- Shizuoka news, yeah.
And, it makes no sense, but
then, a whole week later,
he didn't get caught and everybody forgot!
So, there's that.
- Well!
- Okay.
- But that's a misnomer, that's
not a good representation
of my hometown, it's very
lovely and quaint and wonderful.
- That's like where I grew up, though.
I remember when someone
died when I was like 18,
they were like, "Yeah
this is the first death
"in this area in like 25 years."
Like, murder.
- [Joey] Jesus.
- It's a big deal when it
normally doesn't happen.
- Yeah, in like tiny towns, yeah.
- But that's the thing with like,
especially like Japan, right?
It's like, there's
either no crime or, like,
fuckin'--
- Fucked!
- Like World War III.
- [Reina] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's definitely, there's
no, like, medium anywhere.
But I'm also, you know, I
lived in LA for like 8 years.
Where everybody gets shot
everywhere, at all times.
- I remember the first time--
- You're like, "Someone got stabbed?
"That's never happened in LA!"
(all laughing)
- I remember the first time I went to LA,
it was the first Anime Expo I went to.
- Ugh!
- And I remember, like,
first morning I woke up,
in the hotel, right?
And it's one of those, like, radio clocks.
So, like, the alarm goes off
and then the radio starts playing, right?
- As the alarm.
- Yeah, as the alarm, right?
And I was, like, I thought
that was really cool,
because, like, I'd only
ever seen that in movies.
- [Reina] Oh my.
- So, I was, like, "Okay, you know what?
"This is a feature, I'm just gonna do it
"for this one morning,
"and see if it's like cool
or anything." You know?
'Cause I don't know,
I never had anything like
that in Australia, right?
Or Japan.
So, I was like, "This might be cool."
So, like, alarm goes off
at, like, 8AM or something.
Radio starts up.
"It's a beautiful morning,
here in Los Angeles.
"Last night we had three
shootings happening
"down in the downtown area.
"But it's a lovely summer day today!
"Have a good one, everyone!"
And I was like, "All right,
I'm turning that off!"
- [Reina] Suspect is still at large, yeah!
- I don't want to go outside right now!
- Mind the helicopters
finding the suspects
that are still at large!
- [Joey] Exactly!
- Yeah, that happened.
That's a real thing.
There's always a helicopter
shining like spotlights down
everywhere, at all times.
But it was almost pretty.
- Just trying to go to, like, 7-Eleven?
You get your own personal spotlight?
- You don't go to 7-Eleven in LA.
(guys laughing)
You don't do that.
- That's where it all happens!
- Yeah, that's where it happens!
Don't you know?
- But I want a Big Gulp, geez!
(all laughing)
- It'll be the last thing you ever drink!
- It's Slurpee Thursday!
(all laughing)
- Is that a thing?
- I think it's something like that, right?
- Thirsty Thursday, oh I don't, is it?
- Thirsty Thursday or something like that.
- Well, Thirsty Thursday's
like a college thing
where everybody gets fucked up on Thursday
and nobody goes to class on Friday.
- So, going back to
the whole career thing,
what happened after Crunchyroll?
I'm curious.
- Um, after Crunchyroll--
- Is that when you started
your own YouTube channel?
- Actually, I was kind of
doing stuff on SourceFed
because I felt like it was such a waste
to not be doing something on my own.
And in my head, I was like,
"Eventually, if I leave, like,
"I'll have something to fall back on."
- I think everyone at
SourceFed already had, like,
their own main channels.
- Yeah, yeah, they did.
We were encouraged to
do it to, kind of, like,
also solidify your brand
as an on-camera host.
- So, they were helping
you build up a, like,
way to leave them?
(guys laughing)
- Well, I don't think they realized it,
'cause we actually had
to sign over our channel,
in the beginning.
- Your personal channels?
- Yeah, we had to sign it over.
- Whoa!
- So, they owned that as well?
- Just for, like, a normal paying job?
Like, did you get any
like buy-out fee for that?
- No.
(guys groaning)
I know. Dark, I know.
But, I don't think I was
a monetizable partner channel
until, like, six months into SourceFed.
And then I started caring that, like,
they were taking my money.
- I signed it off, fuck!
- I was like, "They're taking my money!"
But, also, monetization was
different back in the day.
There were no mid-rules, right?
So, there was only like a pre-roll--
- But also the money
was way more, the CPM.
- CPM was way higher, yeah.
- Massive.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, I was not happy.
But, because, like, you know,
I can't do what I did what
I did on Super Panic Frenzy
on my own, I wouldn't
be able to hire Suptic.
Like, that wouldn't be able to happen.
I didn't have editors.
So, like, I knew kind of
what the trade off was.
And I was happy to be doing so well.
So, the security in being a
hired host is much better.
So, I didn't mind.
Especially because I wouldn't
be able to start my channel,
I think, from nothing without SourceFed.
Very aware of that.
- I think you could.
- So nice!
- No one thinks they can, right?
Until you just make something like,
"Oh shit, people want to watch this."
- Yeah, that's literally three of us.
- I think that's like phenomenal.
I do not think I would
have been able to do
what you guys did.
- Did any of you think,
"I'm gonna make something."
- None of us started
YouTube channels like,
"Give me a couple of
years, I'ma be the shit."
(all laughing)
- I remember, like, when I
uploaded my first YouTube video,
after one day, it got five views
and I was fucking ecstatic!
- "Mum! Mum! Mum!"
(all laughing)
- Holy shit, five people
saw my Bleach video?
- It's like, "Mum, you only
refreshed it twice, right?"
(all laughing)
"That means three other people!"
- That is literally, back in the day,
where you had to be, like,
count your own refreshing
into the view count.
Like, you're like, "There's 100 views,
"but I've definitely clicked
on this at least 20 times."
- And I showed this to 20
friends, and my mum 5 times,
that means there's 55 people out there
who thought I was cool.
- Isn't that such a wholesome concern?
Where you have to worry about
your own views and how
much you refreshed them?
Or back when I used to
like all my own videos?
(all laughing)
I need to up the likeage, man!
Like, it's not enough!
- Dude, I'll admit I
still like my own videos.
- Do you? I don't. (laughs)
- Because it's like, dude,
I fucking love this video.
I made it!
(all laughing)
Of course I like this video!
- Fuckin' Obama memes,
just like putting the gold
medal around yourself.
- I literally give myself a
medal every time, I'm like,
"Damn, Joey, that's a fucking good video."
- Joey uploads a video,
"Hey! Who's that guy?"
- My man!
- Who's that guy?
- He's got a champagne
shelf just for himself.
Every video he's like, "Aki,
we're popping the champagne."
- I'm the complete opposite, right?
Because I don't like my own videos,
but because Allen edits my videos, right?
Sometimes there's a joke
where he has to screenshot my own video,
and he always likes it.
And sometimes I get comments being like,
"Gigguk likes his own fucking videos!"
(all laughing)
- Well, I mean, of course you do!
Because you're proud of the video!
- You should be proud of the video.
- Exactly!
- Yeah!
- I just feel like it's not my
place to like. I just (sighs)
- But you're your own account,
you have the ability to like it.
Granted, I don't either.
I only like ones--
(all laughing)
- What??
- I'm sorry!
I've only liked ones where I
collab'd with people, right?
So, like, if Joey and I do a video,
I'll like that for myself.
- Also you want to , like,
"Joey look at all these likes!"
"This is crazy! This is
one more than normal!"
- Oh my god!
- Ah, so sorry, you were saying about
how you do your own channel.
- Uh, oh yeah.
Okay, so, I'd been doing it
and then they gave it back to me,
because I think they were afraid for me
or of me, maybe, when I left?
- I mean, rightly so.
- Companies aren't normally known for
going back on contracts.
(all laughing)
- And kind of owning individuals,
that's kind of scary.
- Actually, we had a new,
like, executive head person
that undid all of that,
even before I left.
Because he was like, "That's fucked up."
Like, "No, these people,
they would be fine."
Yeah, so, he undid that and I left,
it just worked out perfectly,
the timing was good.
And then, I left, I did Crunchyroll
and that was when my own, personal channel
was doing quite well.
Probably, because they wanted to
hear me talk shit about SourceFed?
(guys humming in agreement)
But, also, I had some
like nice people watching,
and they were like migrated
over to my channel,
which was really nice.
And then, you know, I announced
that I was going to Crunchyroll.
So, they were like,
"Oh, it's going to be
even more anime-centric."
Or like, "We get to now hear her
"talk shit about
Crunchyroll." I guess (laughs)
So, that's kind of--
- Reina Scully, "Why I Left Crunchyroll."
- Yeah!
I mean, I wanted to do that video so bad.
(all laughing)
- Dude, I've seen those videos
where it's "why I left this company,"
and the video's like, "yeah
I was just kind of done.
"They're a nice company
though, great guys.
"But yeah, I was done."
And then it's like a million views.
- Ten million views.
- You should've done that!
- I mean, yeah, I should've.
Crunchyroll was a little
bit of a different break up.
It wasn't aggressive
or anything like that,
it's just I still wanted to
work adjacent around them,
and also, because they're
so deeply embedded
in the Japanese anime community,
and I went to like every
industry mixer thing
that happened in Japan,
which was like really scary still.
I mean, back in the
day, it was way scarier.
But, they, like, knew
me as a Japanese person
and I did like voice acting, too, already,
so I didn't want to damage anything.
And I was afraid that even if
it wasn't anything negative,
if I did kind of like a "Why
I Left Crunchyroll" thing,
then maybe companies would
distrust me a little bit?
- Oh, 'cause you're openly talking about
your experiences and stuff, right, right.
- And you know Japanese companies, like,
totally frown upon that, so I was like,
"Lemme not talk about
that at all, ever again."
(guys agreeing)
And, yeah, clean break.
But, then I was doing a lot
of things with Rooster Teeth.
- Oh my god, that's right!
- Oh yeah!
- That was a thing!
- What haven't you done, Reina?
At this point, just start naming companies
you haven't worked for.
- Well, I think, in the nerd world,
I did corner the good markets, right?
- Yeah, you did, you did.
- Gaming, anime, and then I'm just, like,
I don't know, I'm Asian.
(all laughing)
- Reina Scully
- Hire her!
- Professional Asian!
- Skillset, Japanese.
- You know it's a skillset, right?
- That is, that is.
- It really is!
- It really is.
But yeah, I feel like I
cornered those markets
really well to my advantage.
And yeah, so I was doing a lot of hosting,
and also, like, you
know we had the podcast,
the Boys Only Club podcast, and stuff.
And that was really doing well.
Steve was doing really
well with Sugar Pine Seven.
So, I was like,
"Oh, we could totally
do this independently."
Like, "We don't need
a company ever again."
But, yeah, and then I moved to Japan.
'Cause I was like, "I'm so sick of LA."
(guys laughing)
Like, just too truly sick of LA.
- Yeah, LA is hard.
- LA seems very intense.
- It is.
Now that I've been out of it,
and maybe I'm kind of, like,
poisoned ex-post-facto
from, like, maybe COVID,
but I do miss LA.
I miss visiting, I missed the hustle.
It really is Neverland.
Like, I genuinely feel like I
did not age when I was in LA.
And regardless of being there for 8 years,
it felt like I just got
there, all the time.
(guys humming in agreement)
And I don't know, it was, like, it is fun
if you can hit a sweet spot.
Which I did at one point.
But once you lose that sweet spot in LA,
it's hard, it's expensive,
things are really stressful.
- Definitely feels weird just going to LA,
and then just kind of dipping
your toes in that industry,
just for like two weeks
and then being like,
"Whoa, okay."
Yeah, okay, this is a lot.
- Like, going to LA and
doing anything, like,
industry related there,
I feel like I've done a month's work
- [Connor] Yeah, it's so intense.
- of networking and meeting people.
- AX feels like a month.
- Jesus Christ.
- It does, it really does.
- This episode is sponsored by Bokksu,
an authentic, Japanese
snack-box subscription
that sends you small
delicacies from Japan.
- [Garnt] Salty, sweet, savory, damn!
All that umami!
Bokksu has a variety of different
types of Japanese snacks
for you to try every single month.
I didn't write this, Meilyne wrote this.
- [Meilyne] Why did you have to say that?
- [Joey] Not only do you get some
damn good, delicious treats,
they include fragrant tea packets
for you to brew and pair with the snacks.
- [Connor] So, you at home,
snacking on those toxic,
artificial food colored, American chips,
put that down now and
get yourself a Bokksu.
- Disclaimer, this was
written by an American.
I mean, look what's inside!
Tell us, Joey, what do we
have in our box this month?
- All right, look!
We have (speaking Japanese)
This is the thing that you--
- Oh my god!
This is what gave me
the existential crisis!
(Joey laughing)
- Good, okay, I need to
decide now once and for all.
- There's also (speaking Japanese)
Which is a snack that I grew up eating.
- These are good, I like these.
- Those are pretty good,
these are good, too, actually.
(speaking Japanese) gummies.
- Hey, this isn't an ASMR podcast.
Put that down, Garnt!
Bokksu even partners with
Japanese artisan makers
to make sure you're
getting authentic flavors.
That's cross cultural food pollination.
(Joey laughing)
That's in the script.
Anyways, the folks over
at Bokksu have hooked
Trash Taste viewers up
with an awesome deal!
Use our link and code
TRASHTASTE10 in the description
to get 10% off your own Bokksu today.
You can save up to $47.
And don't forget that repeat customers
will get a themed box every month.
So, what are you waiting for?
Start snacking different today.
Back to the video.
- So, how long have you been in Japan now?
You moved--
- This will be my third year in Japan.
- Only three?
- Yeah, I know. It feels
like longer, doesn't it?
- It feels like you were
here before I moved.
- That's crazy.
- Did you ever live in Japan
before or is this the--
- Um, I was here until--
I was born here, and then I
was here until I was three.
And then, I would come back
every summer and winter.
And I'd go to Japanese
school during that time.
I never had summers off, it's really sad.
- Wait, so you had a holiday,
where you'd go on holiday
and go to school on holiday?
- Yes.
It's messed up.
- That's Japan for you.
- Yeah, that is Japan for you!
- That's literally Japan.
- Son, you're gonna love this.
I've booked you for another
six weeks of school.
You're gonna love it.
- Yeah, so in the end,
I would get like maybe two
weeks of summer vacation.
But like, winter, there's no school.
- So, when you were watching
like Phineas and Ferb,
right, and they're like talking about
all these days of vacation,
you go, "That's a fucking lie."
- It was heartbreaking,
'cause like, I'd watch
all these other cartoons
that were like, "Aw, summer vacation"
- Three months!
- "Summer camp!" Blah, blah, blah.
And I'm like, "What is that?
"God, what is that?!"
- "Who has time to camp
"when I have to finish my math homework!"
- It was like, "Wait, I
have this kanji test?"
Like, "I have four
kanji tests coming up?!"
(guys laughing)
"What's a break?"
- So, how long did you do
that for? Until what age?
- Until middle school.
- Fuck.
- Until end of middle school.
So, I graduated middle school, and then--
- That's like 14? 13?
- 13, yeah.
And then when high school came around,
my parents and I got
together, and they were like,
"Do you want to go for
a Japanese university
"or an American university?"
Like, "Where do you
want to, like, end up?"
- Right.
- And at the time, I was
like, "America, duh."
'Cause like, there's this
boy I have a crush on!
(guys laughing)
Like, I'm gonna be here forever.
So, also, like, I only knew of Japan
during the summer and winter,
so I was very conscious that, like,
I don't know how to live in Japan.
- Well, yeah, 'cause you experienced
the two extremes, right?
- Yeah! And I was like, "This isn't fun!"
Well, it was, it was.
But, I was very aware that
I don't know how to live in Japan.
And also my English was way
more superior than my Japanese.
Even after all that schooling.
Maybe I'm just dumb.
But yeah, so I decided I wanted
to go to an American university.
So, that allowed me to drop
all of my Japanese stuff,
because, you know, in America,
you study for the SATs
and you prepare really hard.
So, yeah, that's what happened.
And then, 20-ha years later,
I moved back to Japan!
- Full circle.
- Yeah!
I never, ever in my life thought
I would want to be living in Japan.
- Was that how you imagined it to be?
- Hm, well, you know, it sucks
because the first year I moved,
so, I moved towards the end of 2018.
2018 into end of 2019 was phenomenal.
It's exactly how I envisioned it.
(guys humming in agreement)
Work was flowing in the way I needed it to
and the way it made sense.
I was going back and forth
between the US and Japan,
like, doing hosting gigs here and there.
So, everything like kind of
tied together in harmony.
And then, you know, I keep bringing it up,
like, I can't help it.
COVID hit, and now
everything is so dislodged.
And again, like I said before,
I'm just trying to stay relevant
so that I can have that back.
I can have that rhythm and harmony back.
And so, now, it feels more
like a trying to stay relevant,
catch up game.
And it's just,
it's a little bit weird,
but I'm sure it's weird for everybody.
Like, it was a mess. It's
been a mess of a time.
- I'd literally just moved
here and then it happened.
- I feel like I've only had
a collective experience of moving here
for about like four months.
- I get it, yes.
- Because that's the amount of time
I stayed here before COVID hit.
- [Reina] Totally.
- I don't really feel
like my journey in Japan
has like started yet.
- I feel really bad
for you guys, honestly.
'Cause it's like, yeah,
again, as you said,
like, you guys have been here
for almost two years now.
But it just feels like,
I feel like you've barely
gotten to experience
what it's like.
- It's so different.
- I think I'm very lucky
that I ended up in the one country
where it wasn't effected too heavily.
(guys humming in agreement)
- We do have to appreciate that, yeah.
- Obviously, you know,
it was kind of bad here,
but, you know, we were able
to keep doing this podcast,
we were able to go outside.
Whereas in the UK, it was like,
"No one is allowed to leave your house."
- Yeah.
- At all.
And they were really strict about it.
So, I was pretty glad.
I feel like I kind of escaped.
But then also, on the
other hand, it's like,
I feel super isolated here.
(group agreeing)
you know, it doesn't
help with the time zones,
it's completely different
so you barely get to talk to
people in other time zones.
- I think this is the first ever time
I've ever, like, felt homesick.
And I don't normally
feel, like, home-homesick.
But it was just more like,
man, not being able to see
my family and my friends,
that's different from like knowing
I can see them whenever I'd like.
- Of course, of course, yeah.
- I feel that and this
is technically my home.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like, I haven't been
able to see my family here,
for like over a year now.
(Reina gasping)
- Really?
- Yeah, just because,
like, we agreed as a family
to like not see each other
until COVID was over.
'Cause, like, last thing I want to do
is give my cousin COVID.
(group agreeing)
That would be fucked, so.
- I'm curious, was there
any, like, big reason
or was there like a turning point
that made you think like,
"We're moving to Japan."?
- Well, the timing factor is that
I was just really sick of LA.
But also, during the year
that I decided to move here,
I was going back and forth to Japan a lot.
And it made me miss,
every time I came back,
my wanting to live here
would just explode.
(guys agreeing)
Yeah, it would just get,
like, deeper and intense.
And then, you know, I never
grew up with my family at all.
It was always, like, my
parents are divorced.
And my mom raised me alone,
in a foreign country.
It seems weird saying
America's my foreign country,
but it is.
And, like, I was never a citizen.
I was an immigrant.
I'm a green card holder in America.
I'm a Japanese national.
- Oh, really?
- Oh, wow.
- Yeah! I'm like a hard
Japanese national, so.
Until I married my American husband,
I was never actually an Asian American.
So, in a way, I was like, "I
don't know if belong here."
Like, I know I fake it
and maybe that's, kind of,
just worked its way into
my actual personality.
But, I'm like, my Japanese soul
wants to be with my family.
And my cousin had her first baby
and I was watching her grow up from LA.
And it, like, kind of broke my heart.
'Cause I'm like, "The new
generation has started." Right?
(Connor chuckling) I can't
even be there for that!
Like, I missed the previous generation.
You know, like, my second cousins,
one of them just graduated college.
And I didn't get to watch her grow up,
when I used to babysit
her when she was a baby
and in the summers in between kanji tests.
(guys laughing)
And, I don't know, like, as I aged,
I really felt like I would
be so angry at myself
if I didn't take this
opportunity, right now,
to at least experience living in Japan,
as a Japanese person and
being around my family.
And then, it actually did, like,
the timing was insane,
because COVID had happened,
but then unfortunately,
my grandfather was, like,
diagnosed with cancer.
But I was there for him,
and that's all I wanted.
Like, it would've killed
me, it would've killed me
if I couldn't be here for them, you know?
(guys agreeing)
And, in a way, like, first of all,
he was old as fuck, like, it's okay.
Like, he lived a full-ass life.
(guys laughing)
And he smoked like a
pack of cigarettes a day.
Like, it's fine.
But, like, the fact
that I got to be there,
and I don't have to feel
like there was this big hole
in my life again.
'Cause I lost my
grandparents on my dad's side
when I was younger and I was in college,
and I couldn't get out of college.
I couldn't take time off to go see them.
So, that was, like, always
such a huge stain in my life.
And, yeah, I was like,
"This makes so much sense."
So, yeah.
- I feel really bad
now, 'cause I remember,
as a kid, you'd go to some family reunion,
and your parents, well,
my parents would introduce me to, like,
this uncle or something
and they'd be like,
"Oh, I remember when you were
"just a little baby! "I held
you, I helped raise you up!"
And I was just like--
- [Connor] Who are you?
- Thanos.
Thanos, "I don't even know who you are."
(all laughing)
And now that I've had,
like, cousins who, you know,
have had kids and I've, you know,
held them and seen them grow up, as well.
I know I'm going to say
exactly the same thing!
- [Reina] You're gonna be that uncle!
- I'm going to be that uncle now!
And I know the kid is just
gonna look at me the same way.
- You're gonna be Uno reverse card.
(all laughing)
- You must have so much
street cred with them though.
'Cause my, like, cousins and nephews,
they all want to be YouTubers.
- Really?
- Yeah, and they're all--
yeah, I know, right? (laughs)
- It's adorable!
- That's why I'm really scared,
'cause like, my second cousin here,
he just turned like six or seven.
(Reina gasping)
So, like, he's about to, like,
he's in a fuckin' elementary school now.
- It's great, I love it.
- And it's like, all
elementary school kids,
here in Japan, want to be YouTubers.
So, I am dreading the day
where he figures out that I'm a YouTuber.
- He hasn't figured it out?
- He hasn't figured it out yet.
- You're gonna be the cool uncle!
- Yeah, dude, they love--
- You're gonna be the coolest uncle!
- They're like, "I've never
met you before, who are you."
And then, "Oh, he's a
YouTuber, by the way."
"Who is he?"
- Paying attention now!
- "Which part of the family
is from again, sorry?"
"Do you play Fortnite,
as well, by the way?"
(all laughing)
- "Default skin? Get out of here!"
- It's great, no, it's really funny.
They just immediately like,
"Hello! Hi, I'm paying attention."
- Unfortunately, a lot
of my nieces and nephews
didn't take after me.
A lot of them are just, like,
jocks who love sports and stuff.
I'm just like, "Aw, okay."
- Can never get a--
(Conner drowned out by laughing)
Never get again, never
get a dog, man, fuck.
- God.
- It is crazy though,
that all the kids want
to be YouTubers now.
What's it, like, 35% of Japanese
kids want to be YouTubers?
- More!
More, more, more.
It's way more than that.
- Yeah, 'cause I was googling
it for the UK, as well,
I got curious.
There was like, YouTuber wasn't on there,
it was all, like,
doctor, nurse, something.
I'm like, "That's bullshit."
- Wow.
- They didn't fucking give
these kids the prompt.
Give them the prompt, tell
them they can be a YouTuber.
I bet they'll do it.
- I don't know, is like, being a YouTuber
still looked down upon in the UK?
'Cause I haven't been
there for like a long time.
- Is it looked down upon in America?
Like, would you say it is?
Or is it kind of like, "Oh, that's neat."?
- I don't--
I think it's neat.
I think they claim it to be cool and neat.
- I mean, it's considered
cool and neat here,
for the younger generation.
- [Reina] Right.
- Right, but the older
generation are like,
"That's not a job."
- That's not a job, yeah.
- There's still some of
that in the UK, I think.
- But the problem with that notion,
especially in Japan, is that,
the old people that say that,
are the majority of the
people who live here.
You know, so it's still considered, like,
"Okay, yeah, I guess this is
like the new generation job
"kind of thing, but we'll
never fuckin' understand it."
- In Japan, I'd say YouTubers receive cred
when they go on national television.
Which, it happens a lot in Japan.
- I've noticed.
- Yeah, the moment, like,
(speaking Japanese)
for example, the prime example,
started going on the variety shows,
that's when everybody's
like, "Wow, that's amazing!
"And he edits all his own videos!
"He works, like, 82 hours a week!"
And I'm like, "Bitch, that's all of us!"
- Well, yeah, I think
from the surface level,
it's easy to think, "What a
bunch of fucking weirdos."
But when you actually see all the work,
and you can actually see they're
talented at what they do, I
mean, not me, but (laughs)
you know, you can really
appreciate what's gone into it.
- It is hilarious to see,
like, all these, like,
traditionalist, like,
Japanese TV presenters
being like, "Wait, you're your own editor?
"And your own producer?
And your own host?"
- Cameraman?
- "And your own cameraman?"
"Nah, nah, we don't believe that shit."
- Can I just go on a
quick tangent, real quick,
about Japanese TV? 'Cause I
was watching the other day.
- Oh, please do.
- So, you know the whole meme where,
"hee hee they react to everything."
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I didn't realize they
react to everything.
(guys agreeing)
(Reina speaking Japanese)
(guys laughing)
- So, it was this really, like,
I think someone had
died, some famous person,
and I didn't realize,
they had a reaction cam
for the fucking funeral.
And I'm, like, I'm sitting there,
and I'm thinking, like, "This is--"
How uncomfortable would you be as the host
where they're like, "React,
react to this guy's death.
"This guy's crying at the funeral, react!"
- Yeah, wow.
- I was like, "Am I missing--?"
Like, I don't want to be rude,
maybe I'm missing something,
but I'm pretty sure there's nothing, like,
in Japanese culture that is
like, "You should be reacting."
- [Joey] Oh, no, no.
I've been on Japanese TV multiple times,
it is corrupt as fuck.
- And, like, I get why
the reaction cam is there,
but i was just thinking, I'm like,
"Maybe you, like, should just turn it off
"for this one story?"
- I've seen YouTubers
get canceled for less.
- There's literally just a corner,
and the guy is just like.
(all laughing)
While, like, it's just
a funeral's playing.
And I'm, like, doing my laundry,
I'm like, "What the fuck? What is this?"
- [Joey] It's really weird.
- It's a little lot, isn't it?
Sorry going onto a tangent.
- No, no, no.
So much of Japanese TV
is really hypocritical
to like the Japanese culture itself,
because, like, we pose ourselves
to be so modest, right?
And, like, private and all that stuff.
But then it's like,
"Oh, this person's crying,
zoom in on their face."
But then it's like, when you're shooting
like an interview or something outside,
everything is mosaicked in the background
so you can't like know anything
without their consent or whatever.
It's like there's such a hypocrisy there.
- Yeah, the whole, like, privacy law thing
is just fucking ridiculous.
Like, I remember, oh my god,
I fucking remember there
was one prime example
of, like, it was kind of like
a panel, like this, right?
Like a host, panel kind of thing.
And I guess, like, one of
them had, like, a water bottle
but the entire water bottle was blurred.
- [Reina] What? Branding?
- But there was no logo on it.
It was like the shape of the water bottle
would insist that it's like
a specific brand of water
that's not sponsoring the show.
- Oh, like the Kudo Tea or something?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(guys humming in agreement)
It's like, you know how
like a lot of water bottles,
it's like, "Oh yeah,
that's a Pocari Sweat."
Or "That's like a whatever."
- I guess you can kind of know.
- So, their option, blur out
the entire fucking bottle.
- That makes it stand out more!
- Exactly!
- I can't figure out, with Japanese TV,
why they're blurring some
things and why they're not.
'Cause sometimes, they'll show you shots
where nothing's blurred,
and then the next shot--
- It'll be blurred.
- Everything's blurred.
And it, like, flips between, you know.
And I can't figure it out
'cause it's not like in one
shot there's the branding stuff.
There's branding, there's people,
and then just completely
cuts to complete opposite
and I can't figure out why it does it
and it drives me fucking insane.
- Somebody's just slacking.
(guys humming in agreement)
- They were like, "Dude,
I am not gonna sit down
"and mosaic three more
scenes of this shit."
- Imagine you have to do that
frame by frame, you know.
- And then adding in all
of the fucking, like,
subtitles and shit, as well?
Dude, I feel bad for Japanese TV editors.
- Actually, I did something
with Pokemon last year,
before the pandemic really went wild.
And they had me mosaic, frame by frame,
every single person at a LaLaport.
- What?
- Why?
- Every single person.
- How long did that take?
- At the Pikachu parade.
- Oh my god.
- Every single man,
woman, child, everyone.
Even the staffers, they had me mosaic.
- Why not just mosaic the
entire screen at that point?
- I know, and just, like,
cut out the Pikachu line
that's like walking down.
(guys laughing)
- So, it's like Pikachu
cardboard cutout just doing this.
- I should've just done that!
I'm like, "It's the same thing, you guys!"
At the end of the day. But
yeah, it was so messed up.
And it took hours, and I'm
making it sound like I did it,
my husband did it.
(all laughing)
I made him do it.
- You know, I was slaving away,
watching my husband do the work.
- I was sweating for him.
- Sweating for him!
Three Red Bulls!
- I think we need more vlogs
where people are wearing
the, like, cones for dogs,
where you can just only see in the cone.
"Hey, guys, I'm at, uh, Disneyland today."
Just inside the cone.
- Honestly, and then, like,
I don't know why they do that
for some scenes and they
don't do for others.
'Cause like, there was never
a moment on Japanese TV where,
like, everything is blurred
out that looks good.
- Yeah.
- It just looks like shit.
- It looks ridiculous.
- It's like, "What am I
looking at?" "Where is this?"
What the fuck??
- A lot of YouTube videos
look better than Japanese TV.
- Oh, dude, hundred percent.
- I mean, a lot of their shows are just,
"Send a guy with a camera to
this place and do the thing."
- Yeah, exactly.
- I mean, they can get away
with more things, right?
Because if it's a big Japanese company,
they really, really worry about that shit,
as we find out quite a lot.
- Mhm.
- I mean, there's a lot
of bureaucracy here.
But yeah, I mean, I don't
watch too much Japanese TV.
I'd rather watch YouTube.
- I don't watch Japanese TV.
- It's great inspiration.
They have, like, really bizarre ideas.
Like, there's so many cool
TV shows that they have.
I don't know which ones
I've spoke about on the pod,
like, I swear to god,
I don't know what I've
spoke about on the podcast
and what I haven't.
- We talked about quite a few
in the last one that
we recorded, didn't we?
- Did I mention about
the TV one where they,
basically just, like, go to random people
and they're like, "Hey,
we'll pay for your dinner
"if you take us to your
house and show us."
(guys agreeing)
That was really cool.
- What?!
- They would like go outside onsens,
wait for the old guys to,
like, finish at the bathhouse
at like midnight, and they would be like,
"Hey, take us to your house."
- What would they show at the house?
- Just, like, they're stuff.
- [Garnt] How they live.
- How they live, like, what they do,
like, they're story.
- Is it fun?
- It's kind of interesting, really.
'Cause normally, I guess
everyone normally has,
most people have some
kind of interesting story
about where they ended up.
And especially 'cause I
think, when you're older,
you've lived through a lot of things.
- Honestly, back when I used
to watch a lot of Japanese TV,
I got like a lot of inspirations
for my YouTube channel, all the time.
Literally, like, the reason
why I do so many, like,
quiz based videos.
- (gasping) I was just going say that!
Those are my favorites!
- It's purely, like, all of those ideas,
I'll fully admit, were taken
straight off Japanese TV.
- Yeah, I was just watching,
last night, there was like a
three hour (speaking Japanese)
special, where it's like quiz
god, or quiz king or whatever.
And it's so fun, because
they have all these, like,
Tokyo University graduates
or, like, post-doc candidates,
or whatever.
And they're so brilliant,
like, they're all, like,
Mensa geniuses.
And they know so much about everything,
and, like, even though they
can't, like, let's say,
speak English, they know
more vocabulary than me!
Which is like really gross.
- Can't speak it, but I know everything.
- Oh, I can say, "Mitochondria."
Like, I can spell, "Mitochondria."
- I know it's the powerhouse
of the cell. (all laughing)
- I'm like, "Really? You
knew that in English?"
Then again, it is kind of like
Japanese English, but still.
It's really impressive and it's fun
and the quiz shows are really well done.
- To this day, I think that's
the one type of Japanese TV
I still watch to this
day, are the quiz shows.
- Yeah, I definitely watch that.
- They seem like they're
willing to try out ideas
more than I think western TV is.
I feel like we're very
refined in our ideas.
We like to, like, stick with what works
and just only, like, reiterate
on top of it in some way.
(group humming in agreement)
Small iterations at a time.
And then there's like weird
shows in the UK, actually, so.
(all laughing)
- There's weird shows but it
seems like with Japanese TV--
- [Connor] Everything's a weird show.
- Everything's a weird show,
which is why, I guess, a lot of this
got exported to foreign TV channels.
That's how Japan got it's image
in the first place, right?
- Totally.
- Did you ever watch, like,
the American 'ports of, like,
Japanese TV shows in America?
- No, I was able to watch Fuji TV
when I was growing up in Japan.
So, it was just in Japanese,
so I never really thought anything of it.
- So, you never watched,
like, the spin-off of, like,
Silent Library with,
like, all the WWE players?
- Wait, what the fuck?!
- Okay, okay, what's Silent Library?
- Okay, I thought everyone knew this one.
So, Silent Library is based
off, like, a Japanese TV show.
It was, actually, just one
segment of a really famous
Japanese TV show called
(speaking Japanese)
it's really famous, gone on
for 30 years or something.
And there was one segment
called Silent Library,
where it was five comedians inside of
a proper, like, public library,
and they would pull out of a hat to do
a bunch of punishment games that are
either really painful
or, like, really loud.
Or, you know, get a reaction out of them.
But, because they're in a public library,
they have to be really
quite while doing all of it.
So, I remember there was
one, where there was, like,
one of the comedians gets
fucking slapped in the face
by, like, a sumo wrestler.
- [Reina] What?!
- And he can't make a sound.
Like, he can't make a reaction sound.
And obviously, the other
comedians can't laugh out loud.
- How did they get the sumo in
the library to slap someone?
"Hey, just come in the
library and slap this dude."
- He got paid for that!
- Yeah, true.
- But then, I guess, like, American TV,
I forgot which station it was.
But American TV took that
and replaced the comedians
with wrestlers (laughs) from the WWE.
- I mean, that sounds phenomenal.
- It was actually really funny,
because these wrestlers
would be in a public library,
fucking doing, like, German
suplexes to one another.
Like, fucking full on,
but all really silently.
- And it was still a library?
- Yeah, it was like a proper library!
- What? It was a set.
- It must be fake.
- But still, it was
like, just seeing, like,
all these fucking massive,
six foot, brick shit houses,
doing German suplexes to one
another, quietly as possible.
- Quietly!
- Unfortunately, most British TV shows
do not get good adaptations in the US.
- Oh, really?
- No.
- No, because--
- British humor is weird.
- Yeah, I feel like the
only good adaptation
I've seen is The Office.
(all agreeing)
I would, like, hazard to
call that an adaptation,
because it's nothing
like the British Office.
(group humming in agreement)
- It was one of the few examples
where they took what
worked about The Office,
and did their own version.
It's completely different, but
it works in a different way.
- They still pay an homage to it, right?
- Yeah, the first season is very similar
to the actual Office.
- First season's very hard to watch.
- Yeah, exactly!
- That's what we like!
That's what we like.
- I totally get it, I totally get it.
I absolutely understand, but oh my god.
I just skip right past
it, every single time.
Like, "I can't! I'm so
itchy when I watch it!"
- I love cringe humor.
Love cringe humor.
- Don't get me started about
the American version of The Inbetweeners.
- [Connor] Oh my god.
- That is probably, like,
a lot of people like
to forget that exists,
but it's something that exists.
- I didn't even know it
existed, to be honest.
- Do you know what The Inbetweeners are?
- No, I don't.
- It's this really popular
TV show that came out,
I think when we were,
Garnt weren't you in university,
I was in like--
- No, I was actually in
secondary school then.
- Were you?
Is that when it started?
Oh, finished when I was in sixth form.
- I was the same age as the
characters in The Inbetweeners
as it was airing, which is
why it was fucking massive.
- Yeah, it was huge in the UK.
'Cause it was basically
just four students,
just being, like, pretty accurate students
and just messing up life situations.
(Reina laughing)
And, you know, trying to,
like, get girls and stuff
and being fucking awful at it.
It was just really cringe humor.
- The closest way I can
describe it, is, like,
it's American Pie, kind of.
- Everything goes wrong
for the characters.
- It's scripted though?
- Yeah, it's a drama.
- It's scripted, like, it's a sitcom.
So, it's kind of like
an American Pie sitcom,
but just with British humor
where you see these, like,
four misfits just try to get laid.
And no matter what they
do, it always goes wrong.
- And they just cause awful situations
for, like, everything that happens.
- What? It sounds amazing!
- The British version
is fucking hilarious.
(all agreeing)
I never knew about the American version.
And to be honest--
- You don't want to!
- I don't want to!
I can just imagine.
- It's so bad, it's so bad.
- Jesus Christ.
- This episode of Trash Taste
is supported by Manscaped.
- Gentlemen, you know what I care about?
- What?
- Deez nuts.
(all laughing)
- We're grown men, we're grown men.
Manscaped is the best in men
below-the-waist grooming and hygiene.
Manscaped is taking over the world,
and is now available in all of
Europe, Canada, Australia, New Zealand!
Manscaped is trusted by over
two million men worldwide!
Join the movement for your
below-the-waist grooming needs.
- That's right, Europe and Australia
are about to get a lot less hairy.
If you live in the EU,
you can now purchase Manscaped products!
If you lived there,
you've gone years without using
the right tools for the job.
Now's the time for a change.
- Look, I'm sure all men
can agree with this but
shaving down there, it's a
bit of a pain in the butt.
It's just a little bit annoying.
People always, you know, they're like,
"Ah, I'll do it whenever."
And then never end up doing it.
But, now Manscaped has this
assortment of handy tools.
- That's why Manscaped has
redesigned the electric trimmer.
The Manscaped engineering team spent
18 months perfecting
the greatest ball hair
trimmer ever created.
That was a sentence I just read!
And they've just released
the new and improved
Lawn Mower 3.0!
- God damn.
- Look at this thing.
- Sexy.
The third generation trimmer
features a cutting edge
ceramic blade to reduce
grooming accidents,
thanks to the advanced
skin safe technology,
pioneered by Manscaped.
When I tell you this is
premium, I mean premium.
The battery will last up to 90 minutes.
So, you can take a longer shave, Joey.
- [Joey] Damn.
- And don't forget the
waterproof technology
allows you to groom in the shower!
One of the coolest features,
is that it has an LED light
which illuminates grooming areas
for a closer and more
precise trimming experience.
- There it is, right there.
- [Garnt] They've also
upgraded to a 7000RPM
with Quick Stroke, trademark, technology.
- [Connor] And let's not forget
about the charging stand.
Show your mower off, loud and proud,
because this intelligently designed stand
is a convenient charging
dock powered by USB.
- So, for you viewers of
Trash Taste out there,
you can get 20% off and
free shipping using our code
TRASHTASTE at manscaped.com
that's 20% off with free
shipping at manscaped.com
and use TRASHTASTE
Your balls will thank you.
- Back to the episode!
- Back to the episode.
- No, back to the episode.
- No! Back to the episode!
- Back to the episode, then.
- Are there any other,
like, American shows
that've tried to adapt British shows
that I'm just blanking on right now?
- What's the--
- Task Master had one.
Have you seen Task Masker?
- What is Task Masker?
- It's really popular
comedy show in the UK
that they adapted in
America, it's not very good.
- Wait, Task Master?
- Yeah.
- Isn't that a super hero villain?
- No.
(guys laughing)
- It sounds like a C
Tier, like, DC superhero.
- It's a really, really
popular comedy show in the UK,
where comedians are
told to do, like, a task
and then, yeah, they're judged
on how well they did it.
- Like a really specialized
- Maybe.
- Task?
- Oh god, there's tons of--
- 'Cause otherwise,
like, it's just training?
(guys laughing)
it's just apprenticeship or?
- You should watch it.
Watch it, watch it, watch it.
- Right, right, right, right.
- Intern, "Intern the Challenge."
- So, I guess growing up in Japan,
well, you spending a lot of
your childhood in Japan, right?
Is there, like, I don't know,
I feel, because, as someone who also
spent a lot of his childhood in Japan,
there's certain types of, I guess
anime or shows or, like, manga
where it's, like, it's only
really, like, read or watched by
people who were in that kind of situation,
you know what I mean?
- [Reina] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- A lot of, like, the Slice of Life shit.
(group naming Japanese titles)
You grew up with all that
kind of stuff, right?
- Absolutely, they were my favorites.
Doraemon was so big and huge.
That was, like, my major thing,
whenever I'd come to Japan.
I would record those shows and
I'd bring it back to the US!
- I was exactly the same!
- And I'd watch it, like,
throughout the year.
(guys agreeing)
- It sounds so bizarre to me.
Like, the thought of just, like,
going away to a foreign country study--
- It sounds rich, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
(guys laughing)
- 'Cause everybody
thought, like, I was, like,
hella rich, 'cause every summer it's like,
"Oh, I'm vacationing in Japan."
"I'm summering in Japan."
(guys laughing)
But it's not.
It was kanji tests.
- And then smash cut.
(all laughing)
- It must be like, is it weird, like,
going to a foreign country just having a--
I mean, even then, back then,
Japan was even more isolated
at that point, right?
It must be so bizarre
just having to go back and
forth between those two.
I feel like no one in my school
went anywhere foreign and like
studied there and came back.
- Well, that's because,
were there any Asian
people in your school?
- One Asian person came to
my school, as I was leaving.
(all laughing)
I wish I was joking.
I literally grew up in, like,
the whitest part of the whole country.
And, like, there was, like,
never any foreign people.
- I was only, like,
one of two Asian kids in
my whole school career.
- I was the only one for my school.
- I was the only one, as well.
And, like, I grew up in Brighton,
which is now seen as, like,
the very progressive city.
- Ah, it's like the gay capitol of the UK.
- Yeah, it was the gay capitol.
I don't know if it still is,
but now it's seen as the very
progressive city in England.
But it wasn't like that
when I was growing up,
I'll tell you that.
Because I was literally the
only Asian person in my school.
And my school wasn't small.
We had, like, in sixth form,
we had, like 800 people or so.
- [Joey] Fuckin' hell.
- Yeah, yeah.
My graduating class had,
like, 600 something people.
By high school there were a few more,
but, like, middle school?
Elementary school?
Like, I--
I'm sorry, secondary school?
Or primary school?
- I get confused about this shit.
- I get confused, as well.
- I'm sorry, friends!
- We say secondary school.
- We say secondary school, but, like,
I just call it high school now.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's easier, yeah.
- We've been adopted by American culture.
- But yeah, I don't know, it
wasn't really weird for me.
I knew I got to step into a
different world every summer.
And also, like, I love my family.
And because my mom was able
to bring me back every year,
it kind of stayed tethered.
- Bring you back? (laughing)
Like, "Sorry! Didn't
get the plane tickets!"
(all laughing)
- Just hoist me.
Yeah, like, I don't know.
I felt very connected, so it
wasn't that stark of a thing.
Like, it was just a thing for me, right?
Like, "Oh, every summer I go to Japan."
Like, "Every winter I got to Japan."
Maybe it's because I also
went two times a year
that's also why I didn't feel--
- I only got to go one time.
- You are lucky, though, we
weren't in the same class.
I would've been like,
"Reina, Reina, fucking tell me everything!
"How do they go? What do you do?"
- Really? You'd be into Japan
- Dude, I was! Yeah, as a kid!
- As a young child?
- Yeah, I was, yeah, always.
I mean, I guess that's why I'm
here right now, apparently.
(all laughing)
- I guess it is!
- Ever since a kid, I always just thought
Asia was super cool and, like,
to Europe, it's the
furthest place from you.
- Which is funny, right?
Because people in Asia are like,
"Oh, man, Europe is so cool."
- "Aw, Europe is amazing!"
- Now, I really like Europe.
But when I was growing up, I was like,
"Mum, I don't want to
go to fucking Romania.
"I don't want to go to
Bulgaria." Or whatever.
Like, "Take me to Asia!"
'Cause it all fucking
looks the same in Europe.
It doesn't, but as a kid,
it all feels the same.
(group agreeing)
- I remember when I was,
like, maybe 12 or something.
We were shown "Big Bird Goes To Japan"
in one of our history classes.
- Oh, no.
- And "one, two, three is
ichi, ni, san" was really huge.
And then everybody came
to me, all the sudden,
and they were like,
"Do you have a kimono?"
(guys laughing)
And, like, "Do you pay in yern?"
Like, they didn't know what the fuck.
- [Guys] Yern?!
(all laughing)
- Yern!
- Like, that was, I
think, the first, like,
super fascination that people had.
And I was like, "Really? A
big bird, literal Big Bird,
"made you interested in Japan?"
And they're like, "Really, Ohio?"
Which is a state in the US,
"Ohio means good morning?"
And I'm like, "Yes, fuck."
Like, "Yeah, we speak a different
"fucking language than you, bro!"
But yeah, so, that was my experience
growing up, like, foreign.
- So, there wasn't like kids
who were into the culture
that were like, "Reina, Reina
I gotta ask you things."?
- You know, I had a parent
that was very into Japan.
- Oh, no. That kind of sounds weird.
- Yeah, and, like, she'd really want
her daughter to be friends with
me, because she loved Japan.
(group groaning)
And she, like, always wanted
to have tea with my mom.
Um, green tea.
(all laughing)
- Of course.
That's all we drink.
- Yeah, she was like, "Matcha!"
But, yeah, that was like the only
hyper-concentrated interest,
I think anybody had.
I did not care for this girl.
(guys laughing)
- Yeah, it sucked 'cause I always wanted
to learn more about it,
but you were just so limited
on what you could find.
'Cause I didn't know anyone.
- Other than the internet, right?
- I didn't know anyone who knew anyone.
- Even through the internet, as well,
it all came from, like,
second, third hand accounts.
So, no one was actually,
like, documenting it.
- Right, you can't get
to like really know.
- So, you just have to, like, read forums
and have to, like, piece things together.
- Like, "I think this is correct."
- "I think this is the right
thing, I'm not really sure.
"but I'll ask, I'll look around."
'Cause, you know, I always
just loved games, as well.
And games are like a huge
thing to why I was like,
"Where do these games come from?"
- Yeah, so, gaming was
the other thing, I think,
that brought attention to my nationality.
When DDR came, everyone's
like, "Wow, Japan!"
Like, "Can you sing
'Butterfly' or, like, 'Candy?'"
That was it, that was the biggest.
- That's horrifying.
- I know! I know.
- Were you into DDR, though?
- I loved DDR.
(all laughing)
- That probably didn't help, then.
- It didn't help, it didn't help.
- Just reinforcing the stereotype.
- You're like, "God, fine,
I'll spit fire, geez."
- I mean, like, fuck,
- Do you eat sushi every day?
Oh my god.
- Oh yeah, I guess, actually,
food was a little bit of a deal.
Ramen wasn't that big
back then, but like sushi.
- It's big now, right?
- Oh, huge.
- I mean, Japanese cuisine,
I feel, like, exploded during my lifetime.
It wasn't that big when I was growing up,
but now it's like--
- In the UK, do you think so?
I feel like we still only really
have like sushi in the UK.
- Not even ramen?
- There's the occasional ramen place,
but nothing like worth
getting super excited over.
- The US has completely taken that over.
- Ramen's everywhere now!
- Everywhere now.
- Yeah, but there wasn't
a single ramen restaurant
in America where I'm like, "This is good."
- Yeah, me neither.
- To be fair, it would be hard, right?
- Although, to be fair, in
Vegas, I did go to a place,
a ramen place, which
dead-ass was called Naruto.
(all laughing)
- That gets points just for that.
- Straight up, and I was like,
"Aki, why are we not
eating there every day?"
Fuckin' amazing.
- I became so picky with ramen here.
- You should. As you should.
- It's so easy to fuck
up, I didn't realize.
- [Joey] It really is.
- You know, when you're not here,
and you're not eating the ramen here,
you're like, "Oh yeah,
it's ramen same thing."
But then when you come here, you're like,
"Broth is 4% too salty.
"The noodles were slightly undercooked,
"this is really embarrassing
for you, this is your job."
- You just become, like, an
absolute fucking food snob
when you live here long enough.
(group agreeing)
I never used to give a shit
about, like, the type of ramen.
Or the type of sushi.
But now, I'm like,
"No, no, I only eat at one
specific sushi train franchise."
"Anywhere else, 100 yen sushi?
Get that shit out of here."
- So many of them fuck up the pork.
Like, it's so, like, old and, like, tough.
And I'm like, "What did
you do to this pork?"
- Oh, the slices?
- It has to be like, perfect texture
that just, like, kind of
falls apart in your mouth.
(all agreeing)
Yeah, like, I find myself eating ramen
a lot less in Japan
than I thought I would.
Like, sushi fuckin' slaps
here, I could eat that any day.
- Also ramen takes you out
of business for the day.
- Yeah!
- Like, you can't do
anything if you eat ramen.
- It's so heavy and it's so bad for you!
Like, it's delicious, but, like, it's--
- It is extremely bad for you.
- It's really bad for you!
And, like, you're not supposed
to drink the whole broth.
That's the killer.
- Fuck.
- Sorry, I knew. I looked
at you for a reason,
like, I knew you would.
- You're like, "White
guy, of course he did."
(group laughing) Dude, because
when I go anywhere, I'm like,
"I don't want to feel like
I'm leaving anything."
'Cause I feel rude.
So, I'm like, I look at the guy making it,
I'm like, "All right, fuck, okay."
- Take it all in!
- Chug, chug.
(group laughing)
- I guess I could just
drink the fucking Dead Sea.
- But, to be fair, okay yes,
the sodium is through the roof.
But sometimes, some of the bowls
have like the thank you
message at the bottom
if you drink it all.
- Is that what you're going for?
- That's how they get you!
That's how they literally get you.
- Because I want to see
the thank you message!
- But most of the time there
isn't and do you get sad?
- Yeah, actually, I get real fucking sad.
- I did it for nothing!
- I drink, like, a liter of this--
- Salt.
- I feel awful all day,
I have to like lie down.
And then I didn't even get a thank you.
- The bowl didn't thank you.
- I like to think the guy is like,
"Nice guy, he made my life a
little easier, he cleaned it."
But he probably doesn't give a fuck.
- He doesn't give a fuck!
- He gets the pressure washer
and just (wooshing sounds)
and then it's, like, clean.
Huh, there we go.
- Yeah, ramen, you definitely
get picky in Japan.
But that's also because, you know,
there's a lot of factors to it, right?
Is the noodle too chewy?
Is the broth too fatty?
But it's also, like, personal.
- Also, sometimes, you get like rushed.
And when it's super busy--
- Oh, you do get rushed.
Oh yeah, I didn't think about that.
- All the famous ramen places
in Tokyo always have lines.
And you're expected to eat
it and get the fuck out.
You can't go with friends,
'cause that's not really what it's for.
'Cause there's not gonna
be like three seats empty.
- Well, I know you guys have, like,
constantly told me how
fucking fast I eat my ramen.
- That's a skill.
- It's literally just
I've been conditioned
to eat it that way.
- Joey fucking vacuums
his ramen, I swear to god.
- I'm normally the one
who eats super fast,
and then it's really weird being with Joey
where he just destroys the
ramen. Like, wait, hold up.
- Yeah, well, it's because, like,
when I was still visiting here
and my uncle would take me to, like,
the best fucking, like,
ramen and tsukemen places.
- He's like, "We're leaving.
We're leaving right now."
- It's always like that!
It's always like,
"This stall can only hold like
three people sitting down."
So, it's like, there's always, like,
20 people waiting outside.
So, it's like, if you dilly dally in here,
you're not going to be welcome back.
(all agreeing)
- Yeah, 'cause you can't talk
with your friends when you go in there.
- No, no, no, you have to concentrate.
And actually, it is a skill
to eat ramen real fast.
I eat really fast too,
it like scares people.
But, you know that slurping
that you're supposed to do?
That's like a purposeful thing.
- Yeah, it cools it down, right?
- Yeah! So you can just
eat the whole thing
while it's piping hot.
Which is, like, a really strange--
you're not, weirdly, there to enjoy it.
- Yeah, it's there for a purpose.
- You consume it.
- Sort of like, "Fill my
stomach, get the fuck out."
- Yeah, but there's some places,
the ramen is so good that you're like,
"I need to take my time."
- I know!
(whispers) But you're not supposed to.
I'm just kidding.
- Which is why I'll try and go
at like awkward times, like 3PM.
'Cause normally there's never a line,
no one's coming for dinner,
no one's going for lunch.
But then you've fucked up your
eating schedule for the day.
- Right. I always feel so ungraceful
getting out of the stools.
I'm like, "I look like
I'm two months pregnant."
And I gotta like wedge my way out of here.
- Like, you can the soup just
swishing around in your stomach.
(group agreeing)
- You gotta like move it over.
- The worst is, if you're
getting on the train afterwards,
the moment you sit down on the train,
it's like sleep is activated.
- It does rock you to
sleep, it really does.
That food coma is real.
- But it's so good!
Go eat it.
(all laughing)
- Just don't go to Ichiran, right?
- I like Ichiran, Ichiran's good.
- I remember when you took
me there for the first time,
'cause I'd never been to Ichiran,
'cause I'd only been
to, like, local places.
So, I think it was the day
after our medical exam,
and Connor's like, "Guys,
we're gonna go to Ichiran."
- Well, no, I wanted to
get fucked up by ramen.
- Fucked up by ramen!
- Let's get fucked!
- So, we weren't allowed to eat before.
We weren't allowed to eat from
like 8PM the night before.
Which doesn't sound bad, but
when you're told you can't eat
- Oh yeah, it hurts.
- Then you're like, "Now
I'm hungry." (all agreeing)
- I remember we were eating
it, and Connor was like,
"Go on, how is it? How is it?"
And I'd never had such a hard time
forming an opinion until that moment.
- Ichiran is the most
solid five out of ten.
- The thing I like about it
- That's it, that's it.
- Ichiran is a chain of
ramen that's seen as, like,
very touristy, I guess.
The one thing I do like about
it though, is that you can,
I know this isn't a thing for ramen,
you're not supposed to do this,
you can customize the spice level.
(group agreeing)
I really like spicy ramen,
and nowhere ever does spicy ramen.
So, it's nice that you can be like,
"Hey, but a habanero in
this shit." And they do.
And then you can order, like,
extra meat, extra noodles,
like, it's all chill.
- The customization is fun, yeah.
- The customization is
what gets the tourists.
- It's not the best by any means,
but it's like the most comfortable.
- I like it.
I know that I won't, like,
a two if I got there, right?
Like, a solid five.
Like, I know I won't completely fuck up.
- It was just like a solid five.
And I'm just like, "Well, that
was a meal that I consumed.
"And it wasn't bad and it did the job.
"I am now full, thank you very much."
- Like if you wrote an
IGN review for Ichiran,
it'd just be like,
"Good. Five out of ten."
(group laughing)
There's like nothing else
you can say about it!
- You should go to
Ichiran, it's pretty good.
Check it out.
You should go there first as a baseline.
- Oh, that's actually a really good idea.
- [Joey] I agree.
- And they're all over Shinjuku,
there's like three right
next to the station.
- Oh, are there?
- Yeah.
- Ugh.
- All in the sketchy parts.
When we left that Ichiran,
we literally walked out
and a guy came up to us, he
was like, "You want sex?"
"You want sex?"
And we're, like, literally
in front of the station,
I'm like, "What is happening?"
- It wasn't, like, even late at night.
- It was, like, mid-day!
- It was mid-day!
It was literally lunch time.
- Like, "Do you want
lunch? Do you want lunch?"
- He said it in English?
- Yeah, it's 'cause you're foreign.
They don't bug Japanese people.
- Yeah.
- I remember, I asked this
to one of the bar owners
around the area. I was like,
"Why did they only, like,
"come up to foreigners?"
And they're like, "Oh,
'cause Japanese people
"will call the police."
- Oh, really?
- Really?
- 'Cause the dudes will come up to you--
- I guess it is sexual assault.
- Yeah, they'll put their arms around you,
like, "Hey, where you wanna go?
"You looking for some good time?"
And it's like, "Leave me the fuck alone."
- Ugh.
- I can see the Japanese
calling the police for that.
- Yeah, if I a guy puts
his arm around you,
they're not gonna do it.
And they know the Japanese
aren't gonna talk to them.
'Cause they're terrifying,
I mean, they are.
'Cause they just come up to you
and they're quite intimidating,
they're like pretty upfront.
- "Hi sir, you look different
from everyone else here."
"What are you doing?"
- Yeah, it's fine though.
It is what it is, deal with it.
- Damn.
- So, like, going back to
your experiences in school
and everything, with being Japanese,
were you ever open about watching anime
or did you ever get bullied for that?
- Ooh, um, in American school,
I don't think I ever really brought it up.
It's not like I was trying
to keep it a secret.
- It doesn't come up in conversation.
- Right, right, and I wasn't
like, "These are my interests."
But, oh god, I do remember
something weird did happen.
I had to do a book report
and an autobiography.
And I did it on Sir Arthur Conan Doyle
because I actually, really
do like Sherlock Holmes.
But, I also--
- I already know where this is going.
- I know, but I also like
Sherlock Holmes because
my favorite anime of all
time is Detective Conan.
(guys laughing)
I grew with it, it's like my baby.
It's older than me now.
Like, it's crazy, but
I was obsessed with it.
And all throughout my life, I loved it.
And I loved it, so I
started reading, like,
real Sherlock Holmes, you know?
(group agreeing)
And I was, like,
"I'm gonna do my whole
book report on this."
And I got like really into it.
Like, it was, like, a
15 minute presentation.
- They're like, "Reina, please stop."
(group laughing)
- Yeah, she was like,
"You already got the A."
Like, "Shut the fuck up."
(group laughing)
Like, "Fuck, we get it,
you're, like, an Asian nerd."
Like, "God damn, sit down."
But that was when in
the whole presentation,
towards the end, I started
talking about Detective Conan.
(all laughing)
I was like, I had to
explain something, like,
about his name, right?
And other iterations of his name.
And I was like,
"And in Japan, the most popular anime
"is called, 'Detective Conan'
and it's about, you know,
"Conan Doyle, but it's not."
And I went on like a really nerdy tangent.
- You literally did like
an anime analysis video of
why Conan is called Edogawa Conan.
- Yeah, I did! I did!
Yeah, because Aoyama Gosho
uses different, like,
specifically different
famous literature figures
that are detective novelists
in his book jackets
and they work their way into the anime!
And I was like so excited about it!
And like, Cordelia Gray is Haibara Ai,
because "gray" is "ai."
(group laughing)
- It's a tough thing to learn
as a kid, when you're like,
"Man, people don't care about
the things that I care about."
(all laughing)
- I mean, like, I was fine.
I didn't get, like, bullied or anything.
But that was when I was
like, "I gotta turn it down."
(all laughing)
- I'm weirding people out.
- Yeah, like, I gotta shut up right now.
- I got rinsed for
saying I liked One Piece
when I was like 12.
- What? Why?
- Wait, but you've never even seen it.
- No, I did, when I was a kid.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah, I watched the Four Kids version.
- The Four Kids version!
- Oh, no!
- Well then, I would've
bullied you too, for that.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, they were just like,
"Why are you watching cartoons,
Connor? We're 11, grow up."
- Oh yeah.
- My parents were like,
"When are you gonna
stop watching cartoons?"
And I'm, like, 13, I'm like,
"Am I supposed to stop? What?
This is awesome though."
- My parents kept telling
me, "You'll grow out of this.
"You'll grow out of this."
Here I am, like, about
to go to university,
"Am I gonna grow out of this?
"I'm still really
enjoying this right now."
- Make a career out of it!
- Was there a thing like that
in, like, American schools?
Where it was like they
expect you to, like,
stop talking about stuff like that?
- You know, there definitely was.
And I think I was also, like, a--
I grew up in, like, you
know, late 90s, 2000,
and there was definitely, kind of, like,
a we want to pretend to be
older than we actually are,
kind of phenomenon.
However, I have to credit,
like, Cartoon Network for this,
it's an American television station
that had this thing called Toonami.
(group agreeing)
Oh, okay, okay, it's
not like just America.
That was phenomenal, and
Adult Swim was amazing.
Because they would actually
show like Cowboy Bebop.
And yeah, what was another?
Well, they had a bunch of weird things.
Like Blue Sub 006 was on it.
- Outlaw Star.
- Outlaw Star was amazing!
Yeah, that was a good one.
And then they did like
really, random things.
Like, Candidate for Goddess
and stuff like that.
So, they would have really triple A shows,
and then they'd, like, interlace,
like, the C, B, D titles
(group agreeing)
that were probably less expensive, right?
Just to like fill that time slot.
But it was such a good way
to introduce, I think, like,
this adult theme that is a juxtaposition
to what cartoons are in the west.
I feel like I also then started, like,
cultivating my, like, nerd friends.
And we all would, like, watch together and
we were all gamers, so that
kind of interwoven itself,
it just weaved itself in perfectly.
And I never was like
bullied or anything for it.
- I'm so jealous, because I wish I had
nerd friends growing up.
Nerd friends just didn't exist.
- Growing up in like 2000s,
I got so much shit for being nerdy.
I got shit for playing
video games. (guys agreeing)
- Really?
- Yeah!
- You know, maybe I just grew up in, like,
a really cute little suburb.
- I think I've said this
before on the podcast,
I've always been envious
of the fact that, like,
America seemed to be
way more open to, like,
nerd culture and that kind of stuff.
- Maybe we were, now
that I think about it.
- UK is very much not.
It is now, it is now.
- I feel it definitely depends, though,
on like the type of
friends you had, as well.
Because, like, there were just some--
- I was lucky.
- 'Cause like now that you're so, like,
deeply ingrained in nerd
culture with your career,
was that ever, like, a
switch where you noticed,
"Oh, being a nerd's actually cool now?"
- Absolutely!
But, okay, so, I'm like pretty, like,
headstrong and pretty loud and
obnoxious and I always was.
I was also, like, obsessed with X-Files.
Like, in, like, a dangerous manner, right?
- How is this connecting?
- What about X-Files?
- Well, no, like, it's just so nerdy
and it's, like, kind of older and nerdy
and, like, nobody gives a fuck.
And I'd literally, like,
go around singing, like,
weird songs I made up
about Mulder and Scully
and how they should be together.
(guys laughing)
And, like, I would--
- This is the same people who, like,
this eventually turned into
Supernatural fans, right?
- Oh my god, yes!
And like Charmed fans!
- It's the exact same group of people.
- Wow, I haven't heard
that name in a while.
- Same type of people.
- Definitely, and like, I don't know,
I think I just didn't really care,
and nobody really made fun of me for it,
because I don't know, i
guess there's no reason to?
It's like, "Oh, like, look
at that little Asian girl
"being obsessed with this
like weird alien show."
Or whatever.
(group laughing)
And I was in AP Studio
Art, and I would, like,
I would literally draw Scully and Mulder
and once I drew them fucking.
(guys laughing)
I just, like, I did it.
- You literally drew X-Files doujin.
- Yeah, I like rule 34'd,
like, Mulder and Scully.
And I tried to submit
it for one of my, like,
studio profiles and it got
rejected so fast and so hard.
- I wonder why.
- Well, I know, right?
It was so beautiful.
Not to toot my own horn.
- You know, romantic
embrace of one another.
- It was romantic!
It wasn't like hot and raunchy!
It was romantic and beautiful.
- They weren't fucking,
they were making love,
thank you very much!
- They were making love,
I know, I said it wrong.
- It deserves to be on a roof of a church.
- Truly!
It was very acceptable.
(guys laughing)
- "Tasteful" is the
word you're looking for.
- Tasteful.
- No, I don't know if it was tasteful.
You could see like some nipple.
But like, I didn't understand
why they would, like,
reject it so quickly.
So, I would modify it, and I
would turn it into mixed media,
and I'd put like oil paintings on it,
and then I'd like put some acrylic on it,
so it would like cover some of it.
- You were really committed
to this drawing, huh?
- I wanted it to be submitted!
So, you know, I'd like try to fix it,
but it was still rejected
'cause they knew what
the original one was.
But anyway, my whole point was, like,
I really wore it on my sleeve
without really giving a shit.
So, there was no making fun of me.
It's like, "What, are
you gonna make fun of me
"for liking this show?"
Like, "Bitch." (laughs)
So, I don't know--
- I feel a lot of kids,
though, especially back then,
were not as strong as you were, right?
- It was very empowering
moment when I realized,
"Wait, I can just not care."
And then people won't--
- It's like, "Whoa, you can do that?"
- Yeah, and then people will, like,
not make fun of me, 'cause
they realized I don't care.
- I'm sure they made fun of me in secret.
- But it doesn't matter, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
For sure.
- Just don't care.
It's such a cheat code to life, right?
- Just fuck it.
- Yeah, seriously, truly.
- God damn.
I do want to know, you know,
considering all the stuff you have done,
also the Mochi Gang show
was awesome by the way.
- Oh yeah, thank you so much.
- I was like, "Damn. Nice,
Reina, you killed it."
- That was a lot of fun.
It was a little scary,
'cause in that I had to
interpret on the spot, as well.
'Cause actually, a lot
of the Japanese chefs
that we interviewed in
Manhattan, were just Japanese.
They didn't speak,
like, a lick of English.
- Damn.
- [Garnt] Really?
- Yeah, and they purposefully
found them, it was so good.
Like, the researchers in First We Feast
are so freaking good.
Like, Jackson's amazing.
He was our director, but
he like really went hard.
And we went to, like, this
specialized kabayaki unagi shop,
it was like, it's the only
one in all of New York.
- Really?
- Yeah!
On that shichirin, that,
like, seven coal fire thingy,
and he's like the only one in
all of Manhattan that does it.
And he literally gets the unagi imported
from John F. Kennedy Airport,
and he has to get specialized
FDA passes for it,
because they're live animals.
- Oh, wow.
- Yeah, so, like, they went deep.
And it was hard because, again, like,
food lingo is technical lingo.
So, I was like, "What did you just say?"
"I don't know what knife
you're talking about."
And they're like, "Oh, no, that's not--"
Yeah, it was kinda hard.
But I did feel really special,
'cause they're like, "Only
you would be able to do this."
- Literally, you were perfect for that.
It was so good.
- Thank you!
They even knew I used to be
an apprentice pastry chef.
Like, they went that deep
into researching about me.
- Wow.
- Yeah, and they were like,
"So, since you have like
culinary experience..."
I'm like, "Why do you know that?"
(guys laughing)
- Who told you that?
- I was like, definitely still
using my real name back then,
so how the fuck did you find that shit?
Like, what else do you know about me?
- I thought I scrubbed that!
- Like your entire life history.
- They're like, "This you?"
(all laughing)
- Yeah, and they even knew
what culinary school I got
certificates from in Manhattan.
- That's fucking creepy.
- That's creepy!
- Yeah, they knew where I
learned chocolate tempering,
and they also knew where
I'd learned sponge cakes.
- I don't even know what that word means.
What is chocolate tempering?
(guys agreeing)
- It's when you raise the
temperature of chocolate
to melt it, and then cool it
down and then melt it again,
so that the--
- Oh, that's what you do
with metal to heat treat it.
- Yeah!
(all laughing)
Actually, yes!
- That's what we do in engineering.
- So, that the white
streaks don't happen--
- You heat treat chocolate.
- Yeah, it shocks the chocolate.
- That must've come from
engineering techniques, right?
- Yeah, definitely.
And the real way to do it is, like,
use a marble slab to cool it down
and then you scrape it
again and warm it up again,
so that it really changes the molecules.
- Bro, you probably have more engineering
than I do at this point.
(all laughing)
- Food science!
- Yeah, they frickin' knew that!
What is that about?
- They were like,
"So, in school, we saw
you drew a picture of
"Mulder and Scully fucking?
"What was that about?"
(all laughing)
- Making love!
They're making love!
It's Sistine Chapel shit.
- "Uh, we found a manuscript
of your Detective Conan speech
"and, uh, it's kind of cringe,
bro. What were you thinking?"
- It's not cringe! It was well researched!
It was so well researched.
- I was gonna ask, what's next then?
What do you want to do next?
Like, you've done
everything, I swear, right?
- I really don't know.
You know, we had Gochi Gang season two
and all the guests completely mapped out.
- Fuck.
- And then we had to drop it.
And we postponed it, postponed it,
and then now its completely in limbo.
- Fuck.
- And the US is like doing
pretty well with vaccinations,
so I think that's what
they're really banking on.
So, the timeline is starting
to, kind of, speed up
where they and kinda see the
light at the end of the tunnel.
But, man, it's really hard,
'cause I just, I'm
trying to make sure that,
that happens beyond anything else.
- It's hard to get invested
in anything right now.
- It really is, and I don't
want to have my heart broken.
- It's literally just, "Just
don't get my hopes up."
It's literally just been that
for the past year and a half.
- Just tell me when it happens
and then I can get excited
about it. (group agreeing)
- But, as we talked about before,
Twitch is very interesting.
But also, I've been doing
a lot more voice acting
because a lot of the studios,
especially like more indie gaming studios,
have become more flexible
with their audio specs, right?
So, they're okay with you
sending stuff from home.
And so, that's looking
really fun and good,
during this pandemic period.
But genuinely, I don't even really know.
- Just trying to figure it out.
- I'm just trying to figure it out!
And I think it's almost
okay that we take the time.
That it's like, "What
Else are we supposed to do
"other than kind of
introspect, right now?"
(guys agreeing)
- Do you have a favorite
kind of industry or topic
that you like to work in?
Because you've worked in so many
different industries and stuff.
- You know, I do like hosting.
I think that is really
where I trained the most in,
so to speak, and I'm the most comfortable
being, like, told what to say,
but also have an opinion about it.
- Because you're in a weird position
where it's like, people
know you as a YouTuber--
- [Reina] I know, right?
- But you don't really consider
yourself a YouTuber, right?
- I mean, it's not like a bad thing.
- Dirty word.
(guys laughing)
- I'm not a YouTuber! (laughs)
- Did you just call me
a content creator? Ew!
- I mean, in a way, I actually think
it's more impressive to be a YouTuber,
where I really wanted to be that
instead of a host that's hired for stuff.
- I don't know, man, I think
a host looks way more like--
- Really? I mean, I can't tell anymore.
- "Whoa, that's cool."
- Yeah, it's kind of hard to tell.
- I feel like it's my mood on the day.
- Grass is greener, maybe, too?
- Like, damn, consistent employment?
That must be nice.
- Right.
- But then I guess your earnings
are capped at some point.
(all agreeing)
- And your growth potential
is definitely limited.
(all agreeing)
But, I do miss working
with a technical team.
I miss having a co-host.
And, I guess, I miss a
professional aspect of it.
Although it's not like
YouTube isn't professional,
it's just having to take care of
every aspect of it yourself,
and then if it comes crashing down,
it crashes down on you and you implode.
(guys humming in agreement)
That's really frightening!
- It is super nice just
being able to turn up
and then just do the thing and leave.
- Right?
- That's pretty good.
- Someone else does
everything else for you.
- I feel like really quite
technologically current, right?
But, even streaming for me,
it's, like, confusing at times.
(group agreeing)
Just having to set up and having to learn,
especially looking at Connor's set up,
which Connor says it's easy,
I'm gonna be like, "No, it's not easy."
- I know, he said it before,
like, "You could do it too."
I'm like, "Okay."
- Well, okay, there's
ways I can dumb it down,
take away some things that you don't need,
like all the live sound effects.
- You need to bare bones that shit.
- Literally, the stream deck alone
will up the quality of your stream,
which is like this tiny little thing,
with, like, 12 buttons.
And they all just change
things or play sounds
or do certain things.
And it makes it so much more professional.
And makes it so much easier.
Because I used to have
to pull up the software,
scroll to the thing I wanted to click,
and then change it to the screen.
So, if I want to be like,
"Okay, show all of my face."
All right, scroll.
Oh, I actually want to change
back to the game now, scroll.
But now it's just, like,
press the buttons on the side.
(Reina humming in agreement)
- But there's also times where, you know,
with this kind of set up, for some reason,
you change one setting or something,
you change one setting you
don't remember you did,
and for some reason,
the sound from your game
or the sound from the chat
is just not coming out.
- There's always a technical
issue somewhere, yeah.
- And you just have to go
through this to-do list
where you're just checking,
"okay, is this setting correct?
"is that setting correct?
"I don't event remember what I did
"to set this up to begin with."
It just adds a layer of complexity.
(group agreeing)
- I do think that there's
such a forgiveness in streaming, right?
Like, anybody that is your
fan, that's watching you,
I think they find it charming
that you have to, not like fumble around,
but it's very real, to be like,
"Oh, sorry, like, technical
error, lemme fix it."
And you're kinda there for the journey.
- I guess that's kinda like
the bittersweet moment, right?
'Cause there have been some
moments where I'm like,
"There is something wrong with my stream,
"and I cannot for the life
of me fucking figure it out."
- I just completely forgot something.
- But, it's kind of nice to be like,
"Oh, fuck, sorry guys!
"I'm trying to fix this thing,
I don't know what the fuck it is,
I don't want to end the stream,
'cause we just started."
(group agreeing)
and this is, like, hundreds
of people being like,
"It's all good, bro. We'll wait!"
- Yeah! It's charming!
Like, that's so sweet.
- It feels so bad.
- I don't know, 'cause I get that,
because a lot of people
in the comments section are supportive
but then you start going
through technical difficulties
and then you see that
live viewer count drop,
and it just never feels good.
- If it's something little, it's whatever.
But if it's, like, stream crashing worthy,
it's very stressful.
(all agreeing)
I accidentally shared my YouTube, like,
all my analytics one time
stream for like a second.
- You just accidentally hit the wrong tab?
- Yeah, I accidentally
shared the wrong thing
and I was, like,
"Yeah, guys, that's how much
I made this month, all right?"
- Fucking hell.
- I've done worse than that.
I, okay, so
I leaked the Trash Taste special.
- Oh, that's not bad.
- I've leaked my IP address.
- Ohhhh!
- Which is awful.
That was just the most stressful
realization of my life.
- Are we getting DDoS'd?
Are we getting DDoS'd?
- Like, instant sinking feeling
to be like, "Okay, I got
to fucking sort this out."
I literally unplugged my
internet, unplugged everything.
I googled, "How do I
change my IP address?"
- Fucking hell.
- Yeah, basically, don't test your speed.
Don't test your speed live on stream.
(group groaning)
I didn't realize my IP
address was right there.
- How did you save it?
What did you do when you shared it?
- Luckily, luckily it
wasn't that complicated.
'Cause I googled it.
All you have to do, 'cause I
don't have a static IP address,
all I had to do was unplug
my router, plug it in again.
But, I don't know, at the
time, I was just like,
"Well, my Internet's fucked!"
- Yeah, I feel like, how
you handle the fuck up,
is like the most important part.
When I flashed my thing, I'm
like, "You know what, guys?
"I'll just fucking show
you, just have a look."
- You owned it.
- "You're gonna look at the
clip, just have a look."
And then I was like,
"All right, so I know
it seems like a lot."
(all laughing)
- It's just an estimate!
- YouTube takes 40%.
- You know, YouTube takes a cut.
There's a lot of costs involved.
It's real easy to look at that number.
(all laughing)
- Just fucking sweating.
- I'm like, "You know, tax is like 40%!"
You know, it's pretty brutal.
- So, basically, I see none of it.
(all laughing)
- "What I'm trying to say is, 'I'm broke.'
"Thanks for the $10 donation,
by the way, Tim in the chat."
I'm kidding.
Well, that's what I tell
people when I'm streaming.
I don't stream 'cause like,
some people do it 'cause they're like,
"I want to get more subs."
I just do it 'cause I
like playing the game,
I don't like playing games alone anymore.
(guys humming in agreement)
For me, I don't know why,
I think that's probably a bad thing,
that I've ruined gaming alone for myself.
- [Garnt] Right.
- I only like gaming with an audience now.
I don't know what that says about me,
what's wrong with me mentally.
- That's like literally the only thing
that's stopping me from
fully committing to Twitch.
Is the fact that I don't want
another one of my hobbies
to turn into a job.
- I completely understand, yes!
That's also my other reason.
- I was falling out of love with gaming
and I think Twitch really saved it for me.
(group humming in agreement)
and that's why when I'm
streaming more, it's like,
"Yeah, dude, you can sub if you want,
"but I really don't care.
"You don't need to, I'm
doing this regardless."
And I just hope people
believe me when I say that.
It's so easy to sound like bullshit
when you say stuff like that.
- [Joey] Yeah, of course.
- Try to justify why you have
like 30K revenue last month,
you're like, "Oh my god, um."
- You should've just been
like, "I don't choose the CPM."
(all laughing)
- I'm like, you know, it used
to be, like, I couldn't live.
And now I live comfortably, you know.
It's, like, things change, you know.
(all laughing)
I'm like sinking in my
chair, like, "Fuck!"
- I can't believe you wanted
to justify, that's so scary.
I would've just like cut the whole stream.
I would've been like, "That
was a technical error!"
"Somebody hacked me!"
(group agreeing)
- Damn, Photoshop is advanced these days!
Wow, I Photoshopped my
own analytics, damn.
Would you look at that?
- You shoulda just opened up
Paint and just drawn a three.
Been like, "Oh, no!"
- Just like erase one of the zeroes.
- I think people know, though.
I think, you know, when
you get to a certain size,
people are like, "I expect
you to make some money."
You know?
(group agreeing)
It always feels weird,
'cause I feel like I don't deserve it.
- Well they're estimates
are also, like, way off.
- Yeah, they are, they are.
- [Garnt] Yeah, they are.
- Someone's like, "You
probably make like $500,000."
I'm like, "Are you fucking stupid?"
- It is so hilarious looking
up fucking websites being like,
"The Anime Man's net worth!"
- [Connor] Ten million dollars.
- It's always like ten times more
than what you actually make.
- Because it's an estimate, right?
- The range!
- The range is fucking hilarious.
- It's like, "The Anime Man
is worth anywhere between
"$200,000 to $10 million."
I'm like, "I'm sure I
am somewhere in there!"
- [Reina] Somewhere!
- I mean, I do get it.
Now, that I'm a YouTuber,
'cause for the longest time,
I thought how much I earned
is how much everyone's earned, or like it.
And I've only recently realized,
"Man, CPM fucking matters."
(group agreeing)
- [Reina] What country.
- The subject matter that you talk about
also fucking matters.
Like, I will say this,
as a person who does
anime content on YouTube,
CPM fucking sucks.
- Nah, it's shit.
It's absolute shit.
- I didn't realize how much other people
in the like similar size of me,
was earning in other fields
until people started exposing
how much they earned.
- Yeah, exactly.
- You know, you're so
desperate for a video,
you're like, "Fuck it, I'll
out myself as a millionaire."
(all laughing)
"I'm not one of you guys, I lied!"
- "Yes, I'm a millionaire, what of it?"
- "I needed a video this week, damn it!"
- It's scary, man.
But yeah, again, 'cause, you know,
I've also been thinking of getting,
after what I'm going through,
'cause right now I'm in
a really busy period,
but once I've settled down,
and I can actually start doing
Twitch streams more regularly, it's like,
"All right, I want to
try and figure out a way
"to not make this another
job." You know what I mean?
Because it's like, I've
already done it with anime,
where literally all of last year,
and like a large majority
of 2019, admittedly,
I didn't fucking watch any anime.
'Cause I was so fucking
burnt out on it, right?
After, like, six plus
years of talking about it.
- [Reina] Totally.
- And it's shitty, because
it's like, I still love it,
but I had so much trouble
actually sitting down and being like,
"I'm going to casually watch an anime."
(group agreeing) 'Cause
I can't do it anymore.
- You're gonna be like
ranked watching hentai.
- Right.
- "I can't play casual hentai anymore,
"I need to have ranked playlists."
- Oh, dude, it's like
rippin' my fucking libido.
- I do kind of feel that, because,
it's not ranked hentai or ranked anime,
but you do watch anime and you just like,
"is this useful to my job?"
(group agreeing)
- It's literally like
ranked and casual gaming.
If you only play ranked, it's
so hard to play normal games.
- It's like, "I could be
making a video on this."
And if I don't--
- It's a waste.
- I feel like it's a waste of my time.
- What about when you go
to like 7-Eleven, Reina?
Are you like, "Fuck, I don't
want to make a video about it.
"I just wanted to get a sandwich,
but fuck, I should vlog."
- Oh my god, I always
feel that, all the time.
Like, I always end up taking
videos and photos at 7-Eleven,
even if it's just like in
the middle of the night
and I'm getting a Strong or something.'
- It's good to be B roll, though.
- Yeah, I do and that's
how I always think!
Which is, like, kind
of, I think, unhealthy.
I just want to live in the moment
and drink my three Strong Zeroes
and just, like, pass the fuck
out for the rest of the night.
(guys laughing)
But I'm also like, "Well,
look at how aesthetic it is."
And I'll have to like take some B roll.
Like, "I'll definitely use that
at one point." Or whatever.
But it's also a trap, right?
'Cause 7-Eleven will come
out with something new, like,
literally every three or four days.
And I'm like, "Fucking! I
gotta talk about this shit!"
Now I'm like, "I don't
want to eat any more!"
- Stop being a great company
with great new items for me as a customer.
- [Reina] Their R&D is phenomenal.
- The seasonal products, in Japan,
they're just like a YouTube gold mine.
(group agreeing)
- Japan is a YouTube gold mine.
- It is, it is, right?
- I mean, Don Quixote
was made for YouTube.
- It really was.
- It's like, "Are you
running out of video ideas?
"Go to Don Quixote."
- Yeah, just to be inspired.
- It's not just that, but I think Japan,
as a country, is just optimized
for every kind of fucking
content out there.
My god, I've never seen a country
that is more aesthetic than Japan!
It's kinda not fair!
- You were talking about this
the other day, weren't you?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, 'cause
we were walking down,
what was it, Nakameguro?
- Nakameguro, yeah.
- And it was just this random
street, in this random area.
And I'm just looking around being like,
"Man, that's really fucking
aesthetic, isn't it?"
(all laughing)
My god!
- Garnt, out loud to me, was like,
"I hate how aesthetic Japan is."
"Literally, I could turn any
corner, and I'm just like,
"'Damn, that looks good!'"
- Truly, yeah!
- I feel like, you know for example,
you go to Starbucks, in the UK,
I feel like this is ruining
the architecture, like,
there's such classical
buildings that looks great.
And it's like, "Oh, it's fantastic."
Then in Japan, they look
really fucking cool.
And Japan is so good at
decorating everything.
(group agreeing)
At Starbucks, they have like
100% figured everything out.
(group humming in agreement)
Everyone is obsessed with Starbucks here.
And it's like, they're so good.
Like, the sakura cups, right now.
Like, everything's sakura.
(group agreeing)
They change it next month,
it's gonna be something else.
- It is.
- They've gamed it so well.
- Yeah, and it's just like
every little restaurant,
even if it's just a local
restaurant, or a big chain,
they've personalized their
look so much that, you know,
you can go to a different restaurant
and have a completely different experience
and it's just kind of ruined,
I don't know if "ruined"
is the right word,
but it set my expectations
unreasonably high
for when I go back to England
and everything kind of looks the same.
- Have you ever been to the UK?
- I've never!
Oh! I have once!
I went once for this Sony
Square Enix sponsored thing,
I think it was a VR
before VR was perfected.
- Just droppin' the big
names, just like that.
- Pokemon, Sony.
- No, no! I'm sorry, I didn't mean to!
- I'm kidding.
- I actually wanted to talk about how
it was before VR was perfected,
so everybody threw up everywhere.
(guys laughing) it was,
like, a really big problem.
I was one of them.
- It's like that episode from Family Guy?
Everyone's just fucking vomiting. (laughs)
- It was not that fountain-y,
but yeah it was really similar.
It made everybody sick.
Yeah, but that was the
only time I ever went
and I was so in love with it.
Everything was so lovely and beautiful.
- Is the architecture fantastic?
- I thought so.
- Fuck you, Garnt.
- Is it not?
- He thinks it doesn't look great.
- Garnt's not impressed by it.
- Really?
- Coming to Japan, I'm like,
"Nah, Japan's way more
aesthetic than the UK."
- Oh!
- I think Tokyo buildings
are ugly sometimes.
And, like, really messy.
And, like, dirty sometimes, I don't know.
- It depends on the district,
but I agree with you, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, it depends on the district.
Yeah, there are some
parts where I'm just like,
"Yikes, this is kinda gross."
- Yeah, "Let's turn back."
- Wait, what did you like
about the UK? I'm curious.
- Let's see, our hotel was
a very classical hotel.
- You're very lucky.
- Oh, yeah, I know I was lucky.
And I loved the breakfast!
Oh my god the breakfast was phenomenal.
- English breakfast?
- Oh, it was so good!
- To be fair, English
breakfast is fucking bomb.
- It is good, it is good.
- Fucking amazing!
And, you know, everybody
kinda kept to themselves.
- Yeah, that's what we do.
- British people do that.
- I like that.
- I liked that too.
- It's not British people
keeping to themselves,
it's Americans unable
to keep to themselves.
- That's a thing, yes, absolutely.
- When I moved here,
I felt like there were a lot of parallels
between Japanese and British culture.
- There are!
- Like the way that it's like,
"Keep to yourself, don't make noise."
- Head down, just don't worry about that.
- Don't talk to anyone
on public transport.
Don't do that, why would
you do that? Don't do that.
- Maybe that's why I just
innately really liked it.
But, you know, like you said before,
Japan does kind of have this
romantic, weird, admiration with Europe.
So, I think, culturally,
I guess personality wise,
we're also the same, keep to
ourselves, be quiet and stuff.
But there's a lot of things, I think,
in Japan that like
wanted to be like the UK.
(guys humming in agreement)
- Yeah, I feel like the UK,
we're pretty good at knowing
when to be loud and all rowdy,
I guess. At least I feel like we are.
- What was the drink I had?
Pimm's?
(all laughing)
- Pimm's is good.
- Pimm's!
- Honestly, I fuck with Pimm's.
- What's Pimm's?
- It's like a summer cocktail drink,
where you just put like a
bunch of fruit in a drink,
and it's like 10% alcohol, is it?
It's quite strong.
- It's kind of like a
Long Island Iced Tea.
- But fruity.
- No, no, no, don't say
Long Island Iced Tea.
- Okay, you're right!
(Joey laughing loudly)
I'm sorry, I'm sorry!
- That'll give the wrong image.
- You're right.
- Like a super, super fruity
and fresh tasting cocktail,
that's quite strong.
- It tastes good, don't worry.
- Yeah, it tastes good!
- Well, I thought Long
Island Iced Tea tastes good?
- No, it doesn't!
- Oh, really?
- Long Island Iced Tea's what you take
when you get fucked, right?
- That's true.
- And if you go to a British barbecue,
everyone brings Pimm's.
(guys agreeing)
Yeah, it's very normal.
- Love Pimm's, that was delicious.
I had it like every night. (laughs)
and then, you know,
you'd feel better with the
breakfast in the morning.
(guys agreeing)
But yeah, it was really
lovely, I wanted to go again.
But there's no timing, and
whenever I had vacation time,
I'd always choose Japan.
(guys all agreeing)
- I'm just always curious what
people think about the UK.
'Cause, obviously, when you're British,
you're like, "I fucking hate it here."
"I'm tired of being British!"
- I mean, as a Sherlock
Holmes fan, (all laughing)
I shit myself, like, it was amazing!
- Did you go to Baker Street?
- No, I didn't.
- 'cause the Underground station
for Baker Street has, like,
all the walls have the shape of outlines
of the characters, like in tiles.
- What the fuck?
- Oh, really? That's pretty cool.
- Some of those, the
really historic stations
all the underground stations
have something to have for it,
like, I think where the Globe Theater is,
it's a bunch of Shakespeare stuff
all over the underground station.
- That's pretty cool.
- Wow! That's lovely.
- Japan kind of does that too, in a sense,
but a lot more subtle, I feel.
(Reina humming in agreement)
- I think, yeah, we're really proud
of our history in Britain.
Probably shouldn't be, at some times.
(all laughing)
But some things are good!
The, like, Shakespeare,
forget the colonization stuff.
Uh, Shakespeare!
- Jesus Christ.
- No, 'cause like, for
me at least, as a Brit,
I feel like London's pretty cool.
London's a cool city.
- Sorry, I feel like I
always bring up Britain.
I just love hearing what
people think about UK.
It's really interesting.
- No, I genuinely--
- Makes sense.
- Yeah, of course.
I care about what people
think about Japan.
- Well, let me tell--
I'm joking.
(all laughing)
Go on, sorry.
- I mean, like, London's cool.
London's like really different, I feel.
But London's kind of in it's own bubble.
- Totally different to the rest of the UK.
- You go out of London, and to me,
every kind of place in England
kind of feels the same.
I mean, I would say,
I do kind of miss the
countrysides of England.
Countryside's really fucking beautiful.
But for me, I just don't get
any variety in England, right?
And that's what I love about Japan,
I feel I can get so many
different experiences here.
And, you know, I feel like,
especially in COVID times,
when we have been stuck in
Japan, even in those times,
I feel like I've been
able to be blessed with
a lot of variety in the
experiences I've had.
Even being stuck in one country.
And I feel like if I was
living in any other country,
I would be way more bored than I am.
- Oh, dude.
- [Reina] Oh, yeah.
- I can't imagine fucking
being in lock down
in Australia, right now.
'Cause it's like, dude
there's nothing to fucking do
if you don't have a car.
And you're not even allowed
to like drive around.
Or like, I can't walk anywhere.
So, it's like, "Well
fuck what am I gonna do?
"Look at the fucking same
cockatoo 70 days in a row?"
- What is a cockatoo?
- You don't know what a cockatoo is?
- Is it a bird?
- Yeah, it's a giant bird.
- That sounds bad-ass.
- Don't they talk back to you?
- I mean, they're parrots.
So, yeah, I mean, trained ones can.
- I watched a TikTok of a cockatoo
sing a song by itself
when the owner goes away,
and it was amazing.
- Yeah, we had a pet cockatiel,
which is like a kinda smaller cockatoo,
and we taught it to sing the
Addams Family theme song.
- That's so cute!
- And imitate the microphone,
sorry, the microwave.
Like, the microwave beeping noises.
So, like, it got so
good to the point where
it would make beeping
noise of the microwave,
and I legitimately thought
someone was using the microwave.
- Oh my god.
- So, every now and then,
he'd make the microwave
(vocalizing beeping)
Like, the button pressing sounds.
And one of us would go into the kitchen
being like, "Who's using the microwave?"
- Yeah, that's crazy!
- There'll be an episode of
"Joey's Haunted Microwave" coming soon!
"I feel an aura! Ah!"
- He used to imitate the
phone ringing, as well.
- What?!
- Oh my god, that'd be a nightmare.
- 'Cause we used to have
still a landline phone,
like the house phone.
- My parents still do.
- And yeah, it would imitate that sound.
So, at so many times during the day,
we'd think the phone is ringing,
and we'd walk in, it's not ringing.
- Oh my god, that's cute but
so annoying.
- So annoying.
- It got very annoying.
- What if they could do the
vibrating noise perfectly?
Someone could do that, I knew
someone who could do the zzz.
(vocalized buzzing)
- That's pretty good!
It was kind of, like,
suspicious how good you were.
(all laughing)
- I didn't think it was that hard!
- Yeah, he did go to
the Tenga factory, so.
(all laughing)
- Those ones just go
(steady buzzing)
- Wow, exact!
(all laughing)
- I know the exact model.
- I've noticed Joey is
surprisingly good at doing sound effects.
We were in karaoke the other day,
and Joey just does the R2-D2 sound effects
and the X-wing sound effect.
- [Reina] What?!
- You know, in Star Wars the
R2-D2, when he like screams?
- [Connor] Yeah, I know, yeah.
- Yeah, I can do that
surprisingly really well.
I don't know if I want to do it now,
'cause the fucking microphone--
- It might blow out,
yeah. But later, please.
- Yeah, I'll show you later.
And I can do the X-wing, you
know, like the scream sound.
- What?!
Why??
- I feel like you have to do it now.
- I don't know, I guess
it's just I have a good ear.
I don't know.
- [Reina] Yeah, yeah.
- Anyway, though.
(all laughing)
- Not to put pressure on, but yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Actually, I want to go back
to how Japan is super varied.
Because I actually never
understood that about Japan,
being such a tiny island country
and yet having, even
dialects be so different
throughout all of Japan.
How is that possible?
Like, how did that even happen?
Like, how did we stay so separated
in all of our, like, clans, so to speak?
- Look at the UK, right?
- The UK's similar, where--
- Oh, I guess so, actually.
- There's like 20 different
accents just in London.
- You know what, yeah actually.
- If you drive ten minutes,
it's totally different accent sometimes.
(group agreeing)
And I feel like, if a country's
been around for a while,
it happens, right?
Especially because there was before travel
was widely available, I guess.
- I mean, in the case with
Japan, brief history of Japan,
Japan was--
- 20 pieces, yeah?
- Well, yeah, it was in,
like, 50 different pieces.
And each of them was
technically their own country.
- [Reina] Right, right,
with their own language.
- It was all founded in like the 1600s.
So, for like, over 2, 3,000 years,
each place was just like
a different country.
- Yeah, it just blows my mind.
'Cause like, even, so
I'm in Shizuoka, right?
And I'm on the side that's
rather close to Tokyo.
(guys humming in agreement)
It takes longer to get to
the opposite side of Shizuoka
than it does to go to Tokyo,
and I went there for some kind of job,
and I couldn't understand
the shop keep person.
I couldn't figure it out,
I was like, "I'm so sorry."
And I have a Shizuoka accent in Japanese.
Like, I accidentally let
the dialect slip, and stuff.
But, even then, I was like,
"I can't figure you out."
Like, "Uh, do you speak English?" (laughs)
- Yeah, it's crazy, I had that same thing.
Like, 'cause my family's from Miyagi,
which is like up north, right?
And I have so many of my
grandma and granddad's cousins
who still live in, like,
fucking tiny villages
in the middle of the mountains.
Where it's like, there are some villages
that have their own
village-specific dialect.
- [Reina] Wow!
- And like, village-specific words.
And I remember, one of
them came out to the city
to see my grandma for, like,
first time in like 15 years or something,
and she just came out,
and a lot of Japanese dialects,
they end their sentences
in a very specific way.
- Yeah, the ending is specific.
- The ending is very specific.
All right, so, what's an example?
Like, in Sendai, normally, right,
we end all of our sentences in "beh."
- Ah, "so-da-beh."
- "So-da-beh" instead of "so-da-neh."
- We say, "so-da-rah."
It's "rah" for us.
- "Rah."
- Usually it's "so-da-neh"
or "so-des-neh" right?
Like, that "des-neh"
turns into just whatever.
- Different shit when
it comes to dialects.
- Yeah, so ours is "rah."
- I've been winging it, man.
I just say, "so-des-neh"
and I'm like, "Am I doing it right?"
I don't fucking know, I
just hear people saying it.
- You sound great!
- Yeah, no, that's fine.
'Cause that's, like, the standard.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's a standard hyojungo,
like the standard, regular language.
- But my grandma's cousin, dead-ass,
she ended all of her
sentences with "nyah."
(Reina gasping)
- I love it!
- And I was just like,
"The weeb inside of me
is frothing right now."
(all laughing)
- It's a real thing!
- It's a real thing.
- It's a real anime character, oh no!
- It's like, I thought she
was like putting it on.
But I'm like, "Why would this
like 90-something year old,
"four foot tall grandma be putting on
"her ending of her
sentences, ending in 'nyah'?"
- Joey-nyah!
- Weebs are like, "We've
found the promised land!"
(all laughing)
- [Reina] Go to that village!
- This super tiny village,
in the middle of nowhere in Miyagi,
and you will find a village
where everyone ends their
sentences with "nyah."
- So, these people who are posting online,
were secretly from Japan the whole time.
- The whole time!
(all laughing)
- Oh my god, my eyes are truly open.
- Oh, you know, older people in,
I don't know if it's all
of Japan, but in my area,
"nah-ee" becomes "nyah" for us.
(guys agreeing)
So, yeah,
(speaking Japanese)
right, but like, not
like that though, right?
It literally is like type of ending?
- Yeah, so "so-dah-neh"
would be "so-da-nyah."
(Reina laughing)
It's like dead-ass, like, I
wish I was making that up.
But it's so fucking weird, I'm like,
"That is fucking adorable,
but you're also like 93."
- A hundred!
- You're like 100 years old--
- And you're saying, "nyah-nyah."
- Which one says "uwu" at the end?
(all laughing)
- That's the other village.
- It's in Okinawa, right?
(all laughing)
- They all walk around
like this. (all laughing)
- It's "oowoo" right?
(all laughing)
- That's how they say, "Hello."
- Oh, no.
- Oh my god.
- I'm curious, do you
ever hear a British accent
or, like, an English dialect
that you have trouble understanding?
- Hm...
- There will be one, I
guarantee you'll be like,
"What the fuck are they saying?"
- I mean, honestly, I'm sure there are.
I just haven't come across any.
- Cockney, for me is like--
- That's not even one of the bad ones.
That's pretty tame.
- Really?
- But the more north you go,
the more like, "What the
fuck did you just say?"
- [Reina] Oh man, I've
never experienced it.
- Especially in England,
the more north I go,
you start squinting with your ears.
Just being like, "Uh?"
- Because what they do is,
they start replacing common words
with just their own version.
And sometimes it's that-person-specific.
- Oh my god.
- But everyone around them just knows,
'cause it's like, I don't
know, it's really bizarre.
- Contextual, maybe?
- We've hung out with
you long enough to know.
- Yeah, but everyone just
hears the same thing.
And it's just really bizarre.
- Can you mimic one that I
may not possibly understand?
- Like, there's so many British words
that when people tell me them, I'm like,
"I don't know what that
means on it's own."
But when used in a sentence, I'm like,
"I know what he's talking about."
- I feel like in the UK,
the further north you go,
the more the sentence
just turns into mush.
- Yeah, something like that.
- There was a post on Twitter,
it was like, "What is this?"
And it was, like, British
people were replying
and it was an alleyway.
But there was like 10 different ways
of saying "an alleyway."
- To say "alleyway?"
- In, like, British,
well it's not official,
but like, slang.
And then I saw it because
it was a quote-retweet,
it was like,
"Americans must be losing
their mind right now."
There was tons, I gotta find
this tweet, it was crazy.
- What do you call it?
- I call it an alleyway, but then again,
I've been Americanized.
(group agreeing)
Doing this job, I've had to really, like,
kick out the very dialect specific words.
- I say "cell phone."
I say "elevator" now.
- Oh, really?
(guys agreeing)
- 'Cause I used to say "lift".
- Yeah.
- Every time I've met an American,
- I say "apartment."
- They were like, "What
the hell's a lift?"
- Oh, instead of "loft"?
- "Flat."
- Oh, I'm sorry, yeah.
- Loft? Wait, what are you on about?
Fuck you saying, Reina?
- My bad!
(all laughing)
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
But they're so contextual, though.
Like, you can figure it out?
- Sometimes.
- Sometimes, but--
- If you understand what they're
saying in the first part.
- Of course, of course.
- There's been so many moments
where I thought this was
just a universal word
until I said it to an American
and they were like, "What's that?"
- Oh!
- 'Cause I always thought
like "lorry" for "truck"--
- Oh yeah.
- Was just, like, everyone said it.
- A lorry driver.
- Yeah, a lorry driver.
- How do you spell it? L-O--
- L-O-R-R-Y.
- Uh huh.
- Lorry.
- Really?
- So, it's not a truck, it's a lorry.
- Or, you know, a pram?
Right?
Instead of a stroller.
(guys agreeing)
Like, in America, it's a stroller, right?
You put your baby in a stroller?
- [Reina] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- In Australia, we call it a pram.
- That's okay, in
Japanese it's "baby car."
- (Posh accent) I prefer "baby carriage".
- Baby compartment.
- A pram?
- A pram.
- Pram?
- P-R-A-M.
- But, like, not "pram"
like English A, like--
- Pram.
- Pram, oh, it is a little bit long.
Okay, interesting, interesting.
- But it's, like, I thought
everyone in the world
called it a pram.
And you know, babies wear nappies.
- Diapers?
- No, no. They wear nappies.
- Well, yeah.
- Okay, I was like ,"What
is it then? Tell me!"
I'm like, "What are they wearing?"
(all laughing)
- Yeah, Australian's just give
'em a leaf, like, "Fuck it."
(all laughing)
- Just slap it on, like,
"yeah, you're done."
That was a weird way to fucking end.
(all laughing)
- What a way to end it.
- In Australia, we call them "nappies".
Thanks for watching Trash Taste!
(all laughing)
- (Aussie accent) Well,
grab your bottle of water.
(Australian accents intensify)
- [Group] (echoing) Bottle of water!
(Connor sighing)
- Ah, I guess, where can people find you,
on YouTube or--
- Oh, yeah!
- Yeah, anything you want to promote?
- Sure, sure.
You can find me on YouTube.com/reinascully
everything else is just ReinaScully,
my Twitter, Instagram,
everything like that. But, yeah!
- Maybe on Twitch in the future!
- Maybe on Twitch!
- Maybe on Twitch.
I'll be sure to lurk your
Twitch and never say anything.
- You're right, that is creepy!
(all laughing)
I'll stop, you guys!
- Or type to her in Japanese.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll be sure to, like,
actually scream your name, don't worry.
(Connor speaking Japanese slowly)
- Whenever you see a
Japanese text pop up, like,
now you'll look twice.
- [Joey] Exactly.
- Make sure.
- But yeah, guys, go check out Reina.
- Aw, thank you!
- Thank you for being a wonderful guest.
- Oh, this was so much fun!
I can't even tell you
how much joy I like--
- You know what, it's just
been good to catch up.
(all agreeing)
'Cause it's been far too long.
- Yeah!
And I think we were saying
this during one of the breaks,
but, like, I got to talk
about so many things
I never got to reveal, and it
actually feels really good.
- Trash Taste coming at
you with the exclusivity.
- And also, thank you very
much to our lovely Patrons.
- Yeah, look at 'em!
- Thank you, thank you so much.
- Look at all the names, what's
your favorite one, Reina?
Point to it.
Yeah, there you go!
- Like, here?
- I was gonna say that
one, too! (Reina gasping)
- One person watching this is like, "Yes!"
(all laughing) But yeah,
guys, if you enjoyed it
and want to support the show,
make sure to go to patreon.com/trashtaste
also follow us on Twitter.
Send us your memes on the subreddit.
And if you hate our faces,
listen to us on Spotify.
- [Connor] Is that, like, an
official thing that we say now?
- [Joey] I've said it so many times.
- [Garnt] Joey says it.
- I legit haven't noticed
that you've been saying
the same thing every time.
- I've been saying this for
like 40-something episodes.
- Have you ever shouted out,
like, our Reddit and Twitter?
- No, Joey does it.
- I don't think I have,
I'm just like, "Okay."
- Just leave it to me, boys, I got it.
I got it down to a T. Yeah,
but thanks for coming, Reina.
- Thank you so much!
- Thank you so much for having me on!
Oh, wait! I forgot to give you your gifts!
- Oh, sure, sure.
- Oh, okay!
- It's not much.
So, I thought it would be cute
if I brought a Mount Fuji.
(guys shouting excitedly)
- Let's go!
- But, it's just I think
crispy chocolate things.
But also, and this is kind of fucked up--
- [Connor] Oh, is it? Shit.
- [Reina] Oh, sorry.
- [Joey] Shit.
- Well, our SD cards are full,
so we're just gonna say "bye" now!
Bye! Thank you for watching.
- [Group] Bye!
(chill music)